Go about it.
Go live.
It's true.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Nice,
true.
All right.
We're not waiting for Brian Callen and longer we're watching these fights.
These fights already happened.
Uh,
Eddie Bravo's here.
Hey Cause Brendan Schwab is in the law.
Uh,
the UFC from Fortaleza up Brazil last night.
I did not watch it.
I know none of the results.
I'm so proud of myself.
I've never done this before.
So we're gonna wash these.
Brian Count pretended he forgot what time it is.
He pretended that his phone didn't automatically update like who's fucking
phone.
It doesn't automatically do daylight savings time bitch,
your phone switches over.
Your phone knows what's going on.
Bitch,
most of us have an apple.
I automatically did it.
I had no idea there was a time change the story.
I looked at my watch and I was like,
why is my rock watch wrong?
Like I knew my watch was wrong.
Like anywhere.
Like I just use my phone and then they're like know,
I'm like,
you're a farmer.
I knew because the sun was in up.
Cause my kid wakes up early as fuck.
And I was like,
what?
It is not some little clock man.
Cause the sun would be out,
you know Eddie,
do you know any of the results?
I know one fine.
You son of Bill.
She does.
Cause she did your boy.
Yeah.
Don't even say nothing.
Don't say nothing.
And do you know any of the results?
No.
I watched the,
I watched the prelims and then I was good and I was lucky because I had boxing
Lemieux verse Stephen's,
which was a fucking fight.
Damn I heard it was great.
Some dude got so mert Stephen's gotten murked so bad by law.
You just told me,
you just told me what happened.
You son of a bitch.
Fuck me.
Fuck Bro.
Come on man.
Hbo Boxing,
she dude,
he was out.
I had,
I don't know,
hopefully he's alive.
Let me kill together.
He can crack crack,
crack.
Both of them can and it was in lieu mute came in heavier and if people were
like,
oh he might be out of shape.
And they,
when you talked about a high level fight championship fight and dudes were,
I mean,
they were like,
fuck 12 rounds.
Wow.
It was fun for that.
Did horrible.
Really awful.
What was that fight?
Uh,
I forget the guy who was a horrible fight.
Even Max Kellerman and,
uh,
Lambert were like,
they got,
well,
we apologize.
They were like,
that was a snooze fest.
Hopefully this one lives up to it.
And they said,
I never Apollo,
I can't.
I've never,
I don't think I've ever apologize for a fight that's brought,
I've never heard a guy apologize for a fight.
They would just kind of clowning on it.
Oh.
Like after we,
after sitting through that,
thank God for this flight.
You know,
you guys would never do that ever,
right?
I don't think so.
We'd have to be,
something would have to be really wrong,
but there've been some fights that were really crazy.
I remember that Nate quarry fight where the duty was fighting from the ultimate
fighter.
Goddammit,
I forget the,
forget the fellow's name,
but he was literally running away backwards.
He had broken his foot or some stones.
Starnes thank you.
Literally like backpedaling.
And then Nate quarries starts doing some crazy thing where he puts his hand up
in front of his face and he's just walking him like going like this.
He's like mocking him.
And it was fun though.
And then the dude gave them two fingers but he's just not engaging.
It was real weird at the end of the guy's career.
Okay,
let's it's downhill from,
well Caleb went to fight in some other organizations.
I believe he's good friends with Tate cause they were on the same seats.
That was that season two season two or three Canadian feller,
right?
Yeah.
You backpedaling and gets nothing gets Nate query.
I liked that guy.
But you think he was fighting t RTP doorbell for the waves backpedaling?
It was,
I think he hurts something and I think he was like,
you know what,
these guys are not paying me enough.
You know,
cause I think that was his argument actually after the fact.
They're not paying me enough.
How much,
how little he gets paid.
She signed up for it.
But I think if you,
I think his mind was as soon as he hurt his foot or something like that,
he was like,
fuck this.
I'm just going to get through these,
trying to get that,
you know?
He's like,
I can't hit right now.
I can't move right now.
Let me just look at your doctor bill or whatever.
Knowing that you look at your memory,
you know where your members,
what's up?
Victor Belfor did not look like a t t v tour.
Definitely clean the golden snitches out.
Everywhere he gets to present.
You see the fucking odds on the fight?
Yes.
I don't know who won the fight.
I don't know a god damn thing,
but I know that the odds were crazy and Calvin's favorite.
How did it make sense to one?
Yeah,
it makes sense.
They'll think about beat towards last fights,
gay guard than who?
Weidman before that,
like he just hasn't looked great at all,
especially that first round.
I had to fucking love Calvin at one 85 I know people will say,
what will your Ramiro,
Bro,
I don't see.
I love him.
I don't like him.
With the top five matchups.
See,
I think if he just lifts weights,
it just gets in,
you know,
like serious condition.
I do like him in 25 though in it because all his reach and everything,
I don't know,
man.
He looked pretty God damn good here.
He looked different.
He looked thick.
I mean,
Calvin's never going to look like a bodybuilder that's not as bills,
but he's got it.
He's got a warrior's body like that motherfucker.
He could go for days,
but then you add the muscle to your point you had muscle.
Then what you have veto.
It looks so different.
Peter has that straight up dad TRT bond,
like got off of it and then just straight dad.
I mean,
he still looks scary,
but nothing like the Rockhold.
Vituro hold for me.
Top three scariest fighters of all time.
I was thinking about right there.
There he is.
Look how God Damn Jackie was.
Quick spinning wheel kicks and Shit.
Remember we're maybe beat the brakes off Anthony Johnson.
Yup.
Look at that.
Look at that dog jack.
He is when he threw that wheel because it's shoulder hold everything.
His abs have muscles that you wish she was still like that.
Pardon me?
Does,
yeah,
me too.
You can go to rise him now.
He's no,
he can easily go to rise and to get paid and do that and yeah,
TRT.
We'll look at what truck up cro cop went over there could hook up still doing
it.
You just got to wonder how many of this before I was like 20 years.
Yeah,
he's 20 years.
But I think these guys on TRT,
they can compete
way longer than that.
Even if you let [inaudible] take whatever the fuck he wants and let them go over
to Japan.
Oh,
he's spinning wheel kick in.
Bitches face off against 60 he's going to be doing some crazy shit.
But here's the question.
What he would he be as aggressive?
He was fighting another dude on TRT.
Oh yeah.
You think so?
Just think about back in the day,
think about when he fought Vandelay handling motherfuckers were juice monkeys.
Literally.
He was so aggressive.
Remember?
No technique,
just the lense bodybuilder,
straight punch like this.
We caught him with a straight left and he was wearing shoes.
Yeah.
Fight.
Yes.
Wearing wrestling shoes.
Brazilian on Brazilian crime.
Freisan sticks around and they become like as powerful as pride was and there,
you know,
they just don't disappear like a bunch of other shows.
There's going to be an outlet and a very big outlet for people to retire from
the UFC and get back on TRT.
Like a master's.
Yeah.
Like re re jumpstart their career.
Do you know about one fcs weight cutting,
um,
program?
Do you,
do you know about it,
how bit rich Franklin was helping him with that?
Right,
because you want talking about that cut a lot of weight.
Yeah.
Those guys,
um,
they're,
they've got some new innovative way they think to uh,
diminish the amount of weight guys cut.
I don't know exactly how they're doing it,
but I think it has something to do with hydration test.
See if you could pull that up.
Jimmy Kim,
one FC.
Okay.
Can you imagine in negotiations like rise in negotiations?
They say,
you know,
you wanted to her man,
that's to sell along down.
You just have give it to you being screamed.
Shit,
we'll hook it up for you.
I have it right there on the table
with a needle.
Come on.
Alcohol.
It just highlights of when they're on TRT.
Knockdowns posters.
You walk into the room and there's 20 class screens and v tour.
We'll kick and rock holding the head is things I'll fucked up.
Oh,
in the presentation that just put it county.
Did you lock the door?
Lock the door.
Did you good man.
Well get sit down.
Have a seat top man.
No,
no,
no handshake.
Are you sick?
What are you doing and not calling everybody.
I just knocked the boxer.
Now
have a seat.
Goddammit.
Welcome back.
Put the headsets on.
This is a good fight.
The first fight.
A lot of shit.
First fight.
Of course they did well the first fight Tim means hit him with an illegal need
that a lot of us were unsure of.
I fucked that one up too.
I usually go on these all the time.
See Cause he's got one knee on the ground,
two hands up and we're like,
Ooh.
And here's the thing.
All he had on the ground was a knee.
He actually had even lifted his other leg up and he didn't even have his foot on
the ground.
So it was like,
you know,
there was that whole
thing of points of contact to say you'd have to have at least three points of
contact.
He actually only had one point of contact,
but if it's not the bottom of your foot,
it doesn't count.
So that's where it was so confusing.
Confusing that even mark Ratner,
when we went to him in the fight for clarification on the rules,
he said it was legal.
He said it was illegal knee and then big John McCarthy pulls me over and he
goes,
no.
He goes,
that's fucking illegal.
I go,
okay,
it is illegal.
I go,
so it's when you say points of contact,
like if it's only just a knee,
if only the knees on the ground and the foot's not even on the ground and the
other foot's off the ground,
that's an,
that's a down opponent.
And he's like,
yes,
anything but the soles of the feet,
that's what it should say.
Anything but the soles of the feet.
So my thought was,
well,
what if some guy shoots a power double on you,
right?
And his knees on the ground as he sliding in,
which it often is and you fucking knee him to oblivion as he's moving into that
position.
So it doesn't count,
right,
does it?
No.
Same Way.
But that's not really a transition.
I mean that's the guy making his approach and you're countering his approach and
he has a down opponent.
He's got a knee on the ground.
He's sliding towards you.
I think that's a doubt opponent,
but we will not be the same like with a,
with a wheel kick lifetime,
it's behind the ear buds in transition.
That's a,
that's a creepy one.
I think it's different but similar.
Very similar that we talks about that a million times because it's like it's the
best position to be.
If you get the guys back,
you see a wheel kit coming,
you want to turn your head right,
you want to turn your face and it's like,
no.
You mentioned during your face,
listen man,
there's no good place to take a wheel kick ever except the body.
Like if you,
I would rather take one in the arm or on the body live.
No,
it's horrible.
It's horrible.
It's,
it's a bone breaker for sure.
That's,
it's a,
it's so crazy that you have to pat up your hands but you are allowed to spin and
with all of your body weight,
put it in your heel and and what would he would Edson Barboza did to Terry Adam
remember that one jumping the buses now,
but he was never the same again after that knock out.
I mean never the same again.
Never the same again.
Never fought at that level again.
Never that grazed the top of his head bounced off his head.
You'll see it a million times.
It sounded like a like a melon me person that the highlight,
it doesn't look like it connects flush.
It goes boom.
Top of the head.
Cause I remember it cause there there was these entire flights.
I kept on that and I was like,
God,
it doesn't look like it was a fucking straight up heel to the grill.
I'd have to see it again.
But the amount of power that you have in all of your body weight,
if you have a really good one and you can generate all that fucking torque and
your leg comes up and there's so much weight behind it.
That's one of the reasons why I stopped fighting was a knockout in 19 when I was
19 years old in Anaheim.
I will kick this guy in the head and he never got up and they carried him off
the mat.
They had them in stretch of her half an hour and then they brought him to the
hospital.
It scared the shit out of me.
My heels sore,
my heel,
my fucking heel.
The hard part from his face was sore for days,
like two days.
I was
walking with a little limp do.
I was thinking about that last night when when Steven's got knocked up by
Lemieux and he just laying there and there's a stretcher,
there's like five minutes go by and you'd see them breathe in.
Amex Hellman goes,
well,
at least he's breathing and then his mom,
his cage silo,
all the fun out of the knocked out.
I was like,
Oh hell yeah,
I love you.
I said,
what kind of knock out a box and left hook there?
Exchange left hooks and no,
no Stevenson.
Anyways,
but when he's out on the ground and I was thinking myself,
what's the protocol?
So these being rushed to the hospital,
what are they?
They're looking for brain bleeding there.
I guess the guys out more than four minutes.
You're in trouble.
A lot of trucks they,
yeah,
they mean they have to have really experienced guys who've dealt with those
kinds of traumatic brain injuries on site to get it and handle it.
Right.
That's one of the real issues with those smaller shows where people that want to
do smokers,
if you're doing a smoker,
someone could easily get head kicked with a smoker,
and by the way,
we'll kicks your legal and a smoker.
So think about that.
Think about everybody's wearing those patterns shinning in staffs,
but you're not padding up your heel.
Now,
if someone decides to spin on you and they catch you in the side of the head,
it doesn't matter if you're wearing headgear,
let so many,
we'll kick you in the head.
It's like getting hit by it like a tree like is so fucking big to get an a
baseball bat to your face.
Who you want by your bedside is a Dr. Davidson.
There it is right here.
Oh yeah.
Doctor Davidson's.
Amazing what says to Davidson for the UFC.
Here it is.
Ooh,
what's this though?
And and fast motion.
The sound is horrible.
Oh my God.
What does Alfac left and then falls into this thing and he's like that for the
next four or five minutes.
Oh
my God.
Well,
you know what,
man?
Here.
Exchange of hooks look such a perfect chance
to talk about a power puncher.
Both these boys,
what a perfectly landed punch
your Marilyn Lemieux got dismantled by triple g two which is so impressive in
fast motion and you're like [inaudible] get dismantled.
You got the shit beat out of him.
But he took that fight into deeper water than a lot of people expected.
A tough guy triple g through 50 something jabbed in the first round because he
thought he was going to bang with them.
Triple g you see his jab like Oh my God is he can,
he gets fucking bought like the loom.
You didn't really have a chance the whole time.
He definitely didn't have a chance but he definitely landed some shots.
I mean he definitely tested triple g more than anybody had in recent fights
before that Lmu fan man too.
Like maybe cal Brooks tested him a little bit too before triple g got to him.
But his corner was like,
throw the towel and as soon as it looks sketchy,
they did the right move to,
he's not to get the fuck up but couldn't see out of his eyes.
They were like,
yeah,
good enough.
Good job bro.
Fuck this.
Good for them.
And who is that guy that um,
fought Loma Chenko and pulled out way early.
Oh,
you're talking about the Jamaican fellow,
but he was like,
I think it's 32 and then they're like,
he's never going to live this down.
He wasn't getting his ass whooped.
He was just like,
I can't beat a little bit.
I realize he was so outclassed.
Well that's so much fun to watch.
Amazing what the,
what the guy said in the post fight interview.
He's like,
I saw where this was going
to live to fight another day.
That makes sense.
That's smart fighter.
Kevin says to him,
don't you think you know a lot of people usually we envy those that go out on
their shield.
He's like,
no,
I get that now.
Look.
Lemme Chenko though.
Yeah,
to get the shit kicked out.
There's a lot of times where guys moving around fine.
He looks good on TV,
but he knows in his head that he is tuned up and one shot away from going
unconscious and guys just go,
that's it.
Or He's at just out of tricks or he's just like,
that guy's figured out all my patterns.
He can do whatever he wants to meet and I'm going to be just a punching bag.
Well,
you remember when,
uh,
Nigel Benn fought?
Um,
what,
what the,
what was it?
Homeboy's name?
Gerald Mclellan.
Thank you very much Ron.
Once when he,
yeah,
this is round one of all Avera.
Tim Means it's 48,
49 46 seconds into the or 46.
This should be three.
The number on the clock on the screen is 414039383736.
All right,
sync it up guys.
Just coming.
Thank you.
Jeremy means,
what were we just talking about?
Lemme Chanko uh,
you were talking about,
uh,
oh that got knowing that it was never going to work out for him.
He was just,
he's just getting boxed up.
I was thing that Jeremy Mclellan fight,
like when Gerald went down and like took a knee,
there wasn't like some big punch that landed before that.
It was an accumulation of all the stuff that led up to that moment.
And when he quit they were like kind of shocked like no.
And then he photo the Kodo,
um,
Manny Pacquiao fight and after the third round,
you could hear him.
He wrote Freddy Gone.
You got to take them out.
And when we spoke to Friday after,
I don't want to tell him that,
but he said,
he said,
why didn't he knock him out when he could have been Friday?
Said,
well he didn't want to hurt him.
That's public knowledge and is it?
Yeah,
that was crazy,
man.
Put his corner set to Miguel was like,
if we don't see any improvement,
we're going to stop it here.
This is getting bad at math.
And then Manny just didn't want to hurt him.
He goes,
I could have knocked him out.
I didn't want to hurt him.
Amazing.
God.
That's what a what a nice guy.
What a nice guy.
So weird that he's so nice and yet such a killer right now it's really,
he's a really odd world champion.
He really is in their hands because of stuff going on.
My hair was wild as fuck and then he found Jesus was trying to get up and he's
doing a pretty good job.
Where is his means?
High Level Jujitsu obviously.
Yeah.
Means is full rounded guy.
He's one of the best guys at one 70 he's just like a sh a hair under some of the
other top guys.
Great at anything.
He's just that he's good at everything.
It's fun to watch.
He's great at elbows.
That motherfucker's got some nasty elbows,
good elbows.
I wouldn't say he's not like top five in the division.
No elbows.
I think he is.
I'm saying got five overall.
He might have the best elbows in the 170 pound division.
I'm not bullshitting as aggressive sounding.
I'm telling you his elbows,
especially in the standup positions are nasty.
He throws him real crisp.
He throws him in type positions.
Everything is like real efficient.
It's all done with like real solid technique.
I mean there's better fighters than him currently.
You know,
there's guys that have a full complete game.
This guys like,
you know,
beasts like Tyron Woodley or like Damien Maia,
he meet Damien Maia.
It's just a Goddamn B's top 10 would be tough for him to be tough luck.
That's close.
Yeah.
All have errors all over too.
Good take down.
So you know that what happened in the first fight?
So the first fight was called a no contest because of the knee or the knee.
Yeah.
That's what it was called.
Right.
So confusing.
It was weird because they said it was an unintentional foul,
but clearly he thought it was legal.
So was intentional.
They call him the dirty birds.
Yeah.
Cause we got caught by the golden snitch and I actually won three.
He got caught by the golden snitch with uh,
this tiny amount of some shit that was in a supplement that he bought.
And so they bought the supplement randomly from a store and they found the exact
same stuff.
You know,
look at 10 means body and got steroids.
Well it doesn't matter man.
Instead of taking steroids and they don't really lift weights.
They just train Jujitsu and MMA and they don't look any bigger than everything
else.
Yup.
Steroids.
I mean,
the real thing is the guys that lift weights,
when Lance Armstrong was taking hormones and all the shitty was taken,
he didn't look Jack.
Just the misconception of what it thinks they're going to look like.
Coping just for a to oxygenate their blood.
There are a lot of things,
right,
but it's also the tech testosterone,
AIDS recovery.
But the big thing is the only reason,
the only way you're getting bigger is if you're lifting weights.
Like you're,
it's resistance exercise.
That's what makes your body get bigger.
It's not going to get bigger just by you.
Me Get a little bit bigger just by doing kickbox and lean muscle.
You'll look bigger.
Yeah,
it'll be a little bit,
but not like you never gonna look like,
like Hector Lombard or anything.
Dude,
I would love to see tennis as a random ass fight.
Even Cup was coming off a loss.
I'd like to see that.
Like Donald Cerrone cowboy verse 10 means yeah,
it'd be a scrap.
Wasn't that scheduled at one point in time in Denver?
And maybe I feel like,
boy,
why don't,
why am I fucking scrap?
Oh,
it'd be insane.
That's why I like to watch Tim because it's in,
it sounds like that Matt Brown type of crazy pace.
Well he also has really good stand up and he's a big tall guy and Donald,
you know Donald has that nasty more time.
Really good leg kicks.
I liked to,
Donald's taken some time off.
I love it.
I love those teachers.
Chill.
Just chill out.
Come up with a game plan and make your world champion.
Yeah.
You were so right about how tough that fight was with Matt Brown does.
Despite the victory,
despite the fact that he wanted you got to remember he did get dropped in that
fight.
All we see is the highlight of that head kick butt.
Fuck man.
That was a tough girl.
Yeah,
there was a lot going on.
A Walk in the park.
I saw the new King Kong movie because I'm 12.
Is it good?
Loved it.
Cause I'm 12 toy,
they can't make enough King Kong's for me.
I love them.
This is probably the best one ever.
Is it good guys and not the space movie.
What is it?
But you know what?
They went full on diversity in this King Kong.
First of all,
there's no rape.
King Kong no longer steals the girl.
Every other movie.
King Kong gets the girl and he's like,
oh I got this.
Just runs off of there and this one,
he just protects her and he never tries to fuck her.
And he's so much bigger than any other King Kong in the past.
This new King Kong,
this new King Kong,
literally a girl is not even a lighter in his hand.
Yeah.
The new King Kong is way bigger than the King Kong and the climb the empire
state building son of the old King Kong.
It's a totally new story.
It's a Ribeye.
Can't do that.
They can't do that new story.
Totally new story code.
Completely different style con had a kid,
the all the,
uh,
all the natives on the island are all Asian now.
No more black people.
Oh yeah,
Bob with that is that gorillas should be in the Congo and they shouldn't have
black south Pacific and these is an island that time forgot.
It's a hollow earth and inside there's these demons and then there's Kong and
cons.
Actually the hero,
he protects them from the dean.
That make sense?
Boiler alert.
Okay,
but I know how dare you.
Yeah.
My head to tell you a Khan Kang is in the movie the entire time.
Who are the demon?
Some things that live in the hollow earth.
They live in the middle of the ground.
Round to those guys were like a high fiving each other.
A hug them all the beer and said,
no,
there's no ducking.
We'll kick.
Don't ever pull that shit on me.
Don't,
don't ever bring that shit into my cage again.
Ah,
that's not a good situation.
That's what I say.
When guys try to wheel kick,
I go.
Don't ever bring that shit into my cage again.
Do you ever have candidacies that you use it to someone?
Yes,
I do.
Of course I do to.
But why did you ever wonder why?
Why would,
why would you even want to say that to somebody?
Because I want to be cool.
The earth and everybody.
That's right.
But you gotta understand that if you were that cool person,
you would not have said that.
I know that did,
but my fantasy is to do this.
I want to do this.
If he had done that,
I want to stop,
pull back and go,
oh,
you want a dance?
And then I come in with the,
with a fucking,
that's what I'm worried about with you.
It's like your mind thinks the world is a movie,
like a really shot action star.
Yeah.
Yes,
that's right.
Yes.
Adam Hunter told me he was in a fist fight with someone once and as they were
like,
like getting ready to go at it.
He goes,
the guy he was,
it was a drunk dude and the dude was like,
tonight we dine in Hell.
Oh,
well that's embarrassing.
He really did say that.
Beat the shit out guys.
Spar.
Adam's a nice guy and I believe that Adam was sober at the time.
So,
and Adam's a very good wrestler by the way.
Yes,
he,
I'm pretty sure.
School wrestler wrestling at the same high school.
I think what he did was just took the guy down or held onto him.
I was like,
get this fucking guy away from
it's
tonight.
Hell the savage,
it's awesome.
Just thinks it's like a movie wasn't in a movie.
He would still be ridiculous even if it was run.
If I've never heard that before.
And some games we dine in hell like damn you.
You run the risk of them.
Shit.
I'm not,
I would be saying keep talking stupid.
Keep talking.
The more you're talking more,
it's good bro.
Tonight we dine in Hell.
He know.
Yeah,
I would say yeah I kicked your ass up that.
Tell me more.
Oh,
make up some other shit so you'll be distracted.
When I punched in the face I'd say Sony's record this shit cause these are good
lines before we fight.
This shit is,
but I think the guy was just very fortunate that I was a good guy.
Oh I'll leave here with a bag.
Alverez got his back here trying.
That's yeah,
that,
that was such a bitch.
It doesn't look good.
How do you get out of that?
He got did
and revenge for Olivera.
Oliver can be a little,
oh,
there we go.
Oh,
he's cool.
they're good kids.
I like that.
That's cool.
Don't do that.
He goes,
get up.
Get up Bro.
Don't do that.
Please don't do that.
Those guys that like to do that.
Get on your knees,
kneeling shit in front of each other.
Some dudes just don't play.
Remember pat being cro cop help.
They would just hug hugging in the middle of kick to the face.
Hug.
Yeah.
I fired.
That was weird.
Such a weird fight.
Yeah,
those and didn't Pat Barry like break his hand like real early on in that fight
too?
Yeah,
and then got choked out.
They gave me cro,
cop and Josie.
What comes up to me?
He goes,
you better not fucking Pat Barry and show him too much love.
I was like,
try my best.
I'll try my best.
Sir did take it back with the trip.
Very nice trip.
That's a big win for all of air after losing in a fucked up way.
Because before he lost with that knee,
before that the fight was stopped.
He was getting tuned up.
Huge.
Everybody get out of a body triangle.
How do you do the time?
Do you lean towards the side that it's locked up on?
It puts pressure on the ankle.
There's ways if you have good dexterity that you can clear the leg,
you gotta,
you gotta know how to do it.
You've got to know how to put your weight down and angle your hips down.
And it takes,
it's,
it's a slow process to open up that triangle.
Guys can do it,
but when you're going to in the face,
every time I reach for that,
well it's the worst is when a guy who's got your belly down belly down with that
body triangle,
it feels like your back's gonna break.
It's so much pressure.
That's three in a row for a cub with,
cause that's,
that's not a loss.
The,
the last one,
that's three in a row for homeboy.
Boy,
he's jacked.
Marvel.
Oh,
there's a new marvel.
Thank God it's a fury.
What?
Come on.
It's on Netflix.
Yeah.
Dude was just the Kung Fu guy.
Trains to watch this.
Read this comic book or I'm never heard of it.
It's terrible.
It's going to be the worst one ever.
It was ridiculous hair,
whatever hammered that daredevil one.
Is that still around the series?
I think so.
I think that's pretty well done then.
That's a Netflix one two,
right?
Damn,
he's got,
he's got a fast flash.
I watched Dr. Strange other day.
I heard it's good.
Some bad,
some bad doctor.
Strange.
I was a big fan of it when I was a kid,
so for me it was like,
wow,
this is cool to see them like do their take on the story with all a new special
effects.
I heard that Logan movies,
the shit.
Me Too.
I heard it so far.
The Best Superhero movie.
I saw it.
Didn't you love it Jamie?
It's really good.
Yeah.
Hey Man.
No more
violence.
Be Shot with the throwing stars on his,
on his jackets up dog.
Don't be scared.
Shooty shooty kin.
Impressive.
Thanks for stars are underrated,
man.
I carried them all the time,
dude.
I do.
Y'All want to see Logan though?
Let me look because I heard it's really,
really good.
Yeah,
they're so,
so good.
It's like one of those movies.
You know how like dead pulls up for an award.
That's how Logan supposed to be King Kong is going to beat it.
I'm always down for King Kong,
man,
King Kong,
King Kong
called Kong or come out of my paying attention.
Khan,
Kailyn g,
but you know what the problem is like whenever he gets in a fight with
something,
you know he's not going to get killed by some monster.
Like there's zero drama.
It's always like,
okay,
how's this going to play out?
When is King Kong get to fuck him up?
Because it's going to happen.
I'm not going to let this demon monster thing beat up King Kong and King Kong's
fucking movie.
Now.
That would be a movie,
right?
That's a good movie right there.
Twist.
That's really bad demons and not that stupid guys.
He dies like with 15 minutes left in the movie.
Just get you off guard.
Subtle movie where he gets a virus and he's got a call called ne dice quiet or
he dies right away.
But then the rest of the movie is like going back in time.
What do you think if they think by making King Kong this big,
that trying to set up a King Kong versus Godzilla movie?
Oh that's happening.
It's already happened.
It happened back in the either making it now.
Well then they'll throw some of the vendors in there and shit because now King
Kong is as big as Godzilla.
Like this new King Kong is as big as gods and I don't like that.
Let's live a little more real.
Giant ape would have an advantage of our giant lizard because the lizard
basically I get got its claws.
But tonight as taxi breeds,
oh he does,
doesn't he believes he breathes fire Seabreeze fucking fire.
Oh,
you're not 33 to 2017 look at the difference between all the King Kong's.
See I'm a fan of that.
76 Kong,
not Kong Congress two smalls,
1967 that must be the Japanese version.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
So the original King Kong was only 18 feet tall.
That's not the tile.
So the neutral ones thick.
But the Kong skull island is huge.
He's a hundred feet tall.
That's bullshit.
Well,
how big is he?
Is that skull island one?
So he's a hundred feet tall and Jack Black is only helpful.
He was 150 148 feet tall and King Kong versus Godzilla and 62 in Japan simply to
obey one 40 is huge,
but isn't Godzilla 500 feet tall?
I don't know.
I felt like God's really hide if he is anyway.
Do that guy really got Dylan movie p Diddy Cranston.
Pete did.
He was in it.
No,
he did.
He sang the theme song.
Oh yeah,
that was [inaudible] know it was bad.
That's definitely not good.
Yeah.
Look how big God's will is.
Oh,
Godzilla started off.
He was only 50 meters high,
so he's a hundred what is that?
That's 150 feet.
I like my God,
50 meters high.
I thought that's what you mean.
But there's like a little bit more.
How do you do meters?
I think it's like 3.3 3.333 foot 0.3 inches or something to them.
Yeah.
You like to compare it to yards.
There's like some simple way of doing it.
Like it's like 50 meters is like 55 yards I think.
I think that's up to 14 fucking real similar.
Yeah.
So the 2014 God's was the biggest one.
That was the Bryan Cranston Godzilla.
The old one wasn't even that big.
I like all the latest one.
The latest one was good.
If Saul,
he doesn't,
he doesn't fly here,
but he lives in the ocean.
Dude always listened to you.
Oh shit man.
He's
86,
two nine one seven eight a lot of uh,
nuclear waste.
Yeah.
He came out of the ocean.
And what was because of Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
those bombs that we dropped on Japan,
Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
That's why those monsters came out of there and they were all about radiation.
Mothra camera take sides.
Of course those people were terrified.
Next weekend.
Manoa versus Anderson.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
that's my birthday son.
March 18th what are you doing on your birthday?
Man.
Absolutely nothing.
You not a big birthday celebration and hope don't give up.
Do you want to do a fight companion and your birthday?
That would be fun.
Huh?
That's sad too.
That's it.
Two o'clock here,
Pearl afternoon.
Perfect companion.
Saturday 2:00 PM at a union town this Saturday.
Next Saturday.
This next common one.
Marching coming up March 18th.
That's my son's birthday party.
Uh,
your son's born on March 18th,
16.
I'm on the 18th.
Well shout out to Pisces.
Powerful Pisces.
Do you,
do you follow all the astrology shit?
My mom did.
So I grew up knowing what does it mean anything to you?
Like do you,
do you identify with being a Pisces as it makes sense?
He's like,
sometimes that's me a little bit and it weird.
People think it's bullshit.
I don't know.
You know what's,
what's shocking to me about it is how intricate it is when you look at all the
things they take into consideration when they try to like assess your
personality or what you are like based on your,
you know,
you know where Mercury's in retrograde,
you put all the fucking,
what time of the day was it?
You meet a Scorpion,
she's girl.
She afraid she was freaking the shit and my experience has my scorpions or be
swept into Scorpio.
It's weird about the astrology thing is that there's 12 signs,
right?
Yeah.
And in music there's 12 notes,
right?
Look at the show in here.
The [inaudible] at 19 Yup.
When he fought trade Teledyne John McCarthy.
Oh,
that was him against van underlay.
So gangster dude,
look at the explosion.
Oh,
he was the fiend.
He was phenomenal.
One of the greats.
No doubt.
Mount Rushmore.
Okay.
Yeah.
When you think about like who he was when he first started man,
until Randy coture beat him down.
Yeah.
And then everybody was like,
oh man,
he fought,
I think he was literally 235 pounds.
He was at least that.
Yeah,
it might've been two 42.
I've never seen traps like that.
Miami.
Have you heard the story about a sister?
No.
Sister was killed,
man.
Not just killed the,
they,
they did that thing supposedly that they do where they,
they light you up on fire inside tires.
Cartel Shit.
Yeah.
They still think they call it,
um,
that kind of eat microwaving or something like that done.
You don't get over that.
That's when he got,
yeah,
that was,
that's a beast.
That's how I get rid of the body.
Yeah,
exactly.
They put you inside.
He hires and they a ransom or something from him.
Yeah.
And then they couldn't find her horrible story,
man.
It's scary shit,
dude.
There's some evil fucks in this world.
Yup.
Super Scary.
Yeah.
So he had to recover from all that.
That took a long time.
Then he,
when he went over to pride,
he really wasn't the same guy,
you know,
gross hair out had like that wet Joe curl and then it came back to the UFC and
had some fights where he looks sensational,
you know,
stories like that.
And they ruin literally my fucking day,
you know?
Yeah.
It's hard to know that people are capable of that.
Right?
It's hard to,
you know,
it's happening.
That's happening almost every day in the Middle East.
I mean,
people,
people getting blown up,
civilians,
Mexico.
Whereas whereas going on all over the place of right now,
people are being blown up.
Dude,
I saw a kid,
whereas I saw a family when I was at Disney and wearing a El Chapo shirts.
I was like,
you fucking morons.
You realize what that stands for?
What are you thinking?
So fuck you guys thinking that's so crazy that they think it's spot on.
Funnel cakes.
Did you know?
I want to fucking throw it down their faces so mad.
It's ridic.
How weird is that?
It is your base serial killers shirt.
You want a Bundy while I'll go get you a fucking Ted Bundy one if you want.
As long as you don't know anybody that got killed by the guy though.
There's something about those people that's very attractive to us.
When we see a Tony Soprano on TV or you see any kind of a gang kingpin type
character,
as long as you're not directly affected by his evil deeds or something that's
attractive about,
we'll look at narcos.
Narcos,
we like damn fuck out.
He's kind of pretty cool man.
I feel bad for what he was going to die.
Good Dad.
Yeah.
It's weird man.
It's a weird thing that he's a murderer,
but we like we're rooting for him.
Yeah.
Blowing up planes.
That's thinking about,
you know,
what talent do you think?
Do you think a El Chapo as is bringing in more drugs into the country.
Then like our own government,
our own governments doing it and we're claiming war on drugs and we're bringing
it in,
bringing in more than the cartels are.
Well,
they're doing it in a legal way.
That's why,
that's why the Afghanistan thing is so bizarre.
Not Killing families and stuff.
When you find out how much they've ramped up heroin production in Afghanistan,
if you don't think a few people have died for that,
you're crazy when bombs are being dropped on a daily basis.
That's,
that's just,
that's El Chapo Shit right there for you,
but they can hide that.
They can hide the,
the Afghanistan heroin trade thing.
They can hide it right in front of everybody's face.
That's what's really crazy.
What's really crazy about the Afghan ha ha.
It's all like the paper,
like the actual paper trails.
Undeniable.
There's video of,
I think,
I don't know who it is.
Maybe Geraldo Rivera.
He's standing in front of us in the Middle East.
He's standing in front of a poppy plantation and there's,
there's military guys like Guardian,
and they say that the guarding it because it's the weirdest excuse.
Everett,
what guardian?
We're protecting these poppy seeds because if we don't,
then alcaide is going to come in and then use it and sell it to fund their
operations,
so we got to make sure they don't get ahold of it.
Did you see,
do you remember when Robert got to fire?
He was live on CNN and he's like,
dot.
We're doing a secret mission here.
We're located and draws into the sand.
He's like,
our mission is to go here and there,
like you fucking moron.
Everyone's going to see this knee up fired literally like the next day cause he
gave up,
they gave him like inside access and he drew it in the sand.
What they're playing.
God,
he's a foolish man.
Hilarious though.
You remember when you opened up Al Capone's vault and there wasn't shit in
there?
No,
no big news event.
It was live on TV.
We all sat around and watched.
He don't know.
That's crazy.
Oh Man.
I want to say like 90 10 [inaudible] in there.
[inaudible] 96,
30 million people watching
people watch nothing.
So he ended up it up.
Yeah,
they open it up.
There wasn't shit in zero.
It was a long way.
Jokes.
I mean it was like every news,
every uh,
uh,
late night guy on TV was making jokes about it.
Everyone had jokes about al Capone's vault.
They will ask it for years.
Geraldo Rivera and Al Capone's vault.
Yeah.
You opened it up and taken nothing but he's also the guy live from Chicago.
We're going to open it,
watch this.
Boom.
They got the things falls dam and they opened it.
Yeah.
Look,
he took a chance with dramatic flare,
a chance and it didn't really pay off.
But if it did well now he has to kill time and share it.
I mean he's got nothing in there,
God,
but he's also the guy that had um,
Dick Gregory actually on his television show debuted the Zapruder film,
which is the shot of Kennedy's head getting blown off and going back into the
left classic and in what looks like a shot from the front,
it looks like a frontal shot.
It looks like he was actually shot by more than one person if the,
like if you look at,
there's various interpretations of the Zapruder film,
but one interpretation that seems to make a lot of sense.
He's,
that he was hit from both the front and the back to he was,
there was multiple people shooting at them.
And if you talk to anyone who is trying to,
if you were looked at that pinch point,
like as they make that corner in Dealey Plaza,
like they were like,
well you wouldn't just have one guy with a rifle.
You would make sure you were shooting at them from a,
from a bunch of different locations and Geraldo dropped revenues and Geraldo
showed the video.
Hold on a second.
Here's what's important.
That video was many years after Kennedy's assassination.
Yeah,
like a decade.
So for a decade we had all thought that Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone and there
was only a few people that didn't think he did,
but there was no visual evidence that showed differently.
Hey Lee,
for sure.
Tell us.
Haji,
prude feminist,
it's,
it always baffled me that when you see him get hit,
it looks like for a couple of frames it looks like his head,
half his head disappears and there's just a purple Blob,
like it's a purple blob.
But then when you look at the op to autopsy pictures,
it's just a hole in his head and he just laying there.
But it looks on this,
it looks like it blew it all was tampered with.
That's what it looks.
Well it doesn't look like the film was tampered with,
but the autopsy photographs were most likely tampered with.
And this was a big part of the contention that David Liftin had when he wrote
the book best evidence because there's two different,
let's watch this.
We'll see like a perpetual offer.
Two frames doesn't make any sense.
Spray the bullets,
hitting his head,
his heads.
When you hit something with a bullet,
there's a spray.
It looks like his,
his whole face just flies off and they're just,
well,
they say that his,
his peace of his head flew off and she crawled to on the back to try to put his
head back to which is a human being to know.
She didn't know she did.
No,
did not say that.
That's not what happened.
She was trying to get the fuck out of that limousine because people were
shooting and they blew her husband's head off.
She wasn't going for any piece of meat.
I heard that now she was reaching,
people say crazy shit like that does not.
She was getting the fuck.
Did she ever talk about Barbara talked about it.
I go,
oh,
she never talked to him for,
you know,
Jackie Onassis right afterwards.
She married like one of the richest people she could find.
But don't you think with that autopsy they,
they,
it's your president that just got assassinated.
So you're going to want to make him look the best politics.
Look at the video,
the supporter for him.
What does that mean?
Explain,
cause this is something that I'm really,
I've read different books on this shit and I've watched 10 or 15 documentaries.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the big things is there's a giant difference between the account of the
autopsy,
what,
what they said,
their description of the body and the wounds in Dallas versus their description
and the wounds in Bethesda,
Maryland,
two very different autopsies.
One of them that shows an entrance wound on the neck shows he got shot from the
front and an exit wound or an entrance wound on his neck on another one that was
changed to a tracheotomy scar.
So there's a discrepancy.
He grabs his neck,
it like he got hit,
he holds his neck maybe a second or two before his brain's blowout.
Right.
And when he's holding his neck like this on one autopsy,
on one account of the body,
that's an entrance wound from a bullet.
That's the Dallas one.
But on another one,
see if you see him when he's going around the corner here,
he's already holding his neck.
Look at how he's holding his neck like that.
He reached up and grabbed himself and he's looking down and ride around.
He passes the pole and his head blows off.
Watch this right here.
Boom.
What else?
Hang on.
Start again.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
it'd be good to get out the way.
This isn't super slowly
disappears,
right?
They're like,
what is that?
It's like a flower.
It's just a flap of bone and meet it opened his headlight out.
So watch,
look,
she ain't go in searching for a piece of hair and she's trying to get the fuck
off of that.
Well,
we don't know when the service guy right behind you,
bro,
that's the secret service guy has climbed up at the back of the car and he's
reaching for her to help her.
Oh my God,
what a horrible,
so,
but the problem was nobody had seen that until 10 years after the assassination.
So when they watch it,
they go,
oh my God,
his head goes back into the left.
That was like that Hicks joke that he kept talking about backing to the left,
back into the left.
I mean his,
he got shot,
it looked like he was getting shot from the front and it hit the right side of
his head and his head goes back into the left.
But there's also some spray that appears to be either going forward,
it could be an impact spray or the bullet from the front,
or it could be that he got shot with two different bullets at the same time.
There's,
there's,
it's very possible that he got hit from the front and the back.
[inaudible] it's basically very hard to tell what happened with one angle.
Right.
Well,
you know for sure he got shot in the head.
His head blew apart.
What's crazy to me after all these years,
we don't know for a fact.
No,
they can't.
There's no way they can know that came out and watch it again.
Watch this again.
Now Watch,
watch.
It's hard to tell if this is an impact spray or if it's an exit.
Where's his head at?
His head is right there.
It's like an impact right there.
Hey Man.
But could be,
it could be an impact spray from the front.
Meanwhile it,
it very well could be that it's an exit spray too.
But the thing is his head goes back into the left.
But here's the question.
Does it go back to the left from the momentum of getting hit in the head with a
bullet or is it a spasm from a dying body like your,
your body locks up and it just throws itself into a convulsion.
That's possible too.
I mean a lot of crazy shit happens when you get shot in the fucking head.
And he was a real cocksman too.
I bet he was.
But I don't think that had anything cause you don't think I'm just saying to be
Harvey Oswald acted alone.
I do not think Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone.
I do not.
I do not think that even,
uh,
even reasonable to assume that he acted alone.
There's way,
way too many people that invest in interest in killing him.
Like a Cubans,
like every,
there was a lot of people,
there was a lot of people that wanted him dead.
And it depends on what varying version of the story you're willing to buy into.
But what is possible,
and this is one thing that people don't want to consider,
they think either Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone or at some wacky tinfoil hat
conspiracy.
I say neither.
I say it might be both.
I say Lee Harvey Oswald could have been in on it.
He seemed like a,
like a gullible guy and a lot of ways.
Right.
He'd been to Russia.
You've been rushed too,
but he lived in Russia.
He's married to a Russian woman,
Lee Harvey Oswald was most certainly at least in cahoots with the FBI.
He definitely,
yes,
he,
well,
he definitely did some things for other organizations.
Uh,
and brought over during the Cold War.
A Russian wife lived over in Russia and then got back in the United States and
brought over as Russia.
We did also going to Cuba,
right?
Didn't he spent time in Cuba believe?
I believe he did.
I don't,
I don't remember that.
But I know for a fact he lived in Russia.
Communist spoke Russian,
but he was part of a,
a Cuban movement,
like a liberty for Cuba.
Cuba.
I spent time in Cuba.
Might have,
he didn't go to Cuba.
Okay,
well Jamie,
you'll find it.
But the,
but the bottom line is he easily could have been working for the government and
he easily could have been a part of the plan and he easily could have been a guy
that they fell maybe was,
yeah,
they set him up.
Is he still alive?
No,
we got shot by Jack Ruby like a couple days after he shot Kennedy or allegedly
shot 10
died of cancer in jail.
Not only that,
Jack Ruby was a mob guy that was deeply beholden to all these different groups
and you know,
which is very weird.
Right.
Why?
Why would Jack Ruby,
a mob guy kill,
can meet Harvey Oswald in broad daylight while he's being escorted?
Like what?
What would they,
they were like,
well,
he felt so bad for Jackie.
That doesn't make any sense.
The JFK story is vast.
It would take you fucking 25 hours.
People have written books on it.
I mean,
it's so deep.
Everybody want JFK debt.
The CII wanted them to get oh,
MCS and in Cuba and so union,
so he wasn't killing oil.
One that everybody wanted him dead.
So was trying to change the world.
He visited embassies and Cuba and the Soviet Union to plot his escape before
assassinating John F.
Kennedy.
I think he was in on it.
That's what I think.
For sure.
Yeah.
Leo Oswald didn't act alone,
but I do believe he was in on it and I bet he didn't pull the trigger.
I bet a bunch of other people pull the trigger and a bet.
Who's the,
he was the guy they set up command.
Yeah,
because like Dallas,
no,
Howard hunt is,
yes.
He,
Howard hunt was in the CIA.
He was part of a Watergate.
He's,
he's very big in the CIA on his deathbed.
He says that,
uh,
that was all the assassins from
operation 40 operations.
40 was a unit that,
that um,
they put together to assassinate Fidel Castro,
all these international killers.
It's just like,
uh,
like the murder incorporated operation it,
yeah,
exactly.
All these,
these,
uh,
snipers and killers,
anti Castro,
Cubans,
you know,
there were exiled.
They all got together.
They tried to kill Fidel Castro.
Bay of Pigs failed.
Um,
uh,
because JFK made,
part of the reason was because,
uh,
JFK didn't,
um,
he,
uh,
he didn't want any air support.
He didn't want to be any part.
He didn't want any part of Bay of pigs.
So the CIA felt like they got abandoned by JFK.
JFK fires the head of the CIA.
So right there there's a big rift between the CIA and JFK.
The mob hated JFK too,
because they were supposed to protect them up.
Robert Kennedy and JFK,
but because their dad was a mobster,
so they thought they were going to be protected.
So the mom spent all this money to get JFK n and then he's turning on him and,
and Robert Kennedy's brother,
he's the attorney general.
He's going after the mob.
So they're like,
okay,
we got to stop these months.
So when you look,
when you look really,
really look into it,
a lot of people wanted him dead.
Big Oil wanted him dead.
They killed them in Texas.
Lyndon B Johnson,
the vice president was about to be indicted for tumors.
He had the,
you know how uh,
he stopped that.
JFK got assassinated.
He becomes president.
He pardons himself.
He was a crazy time,
was not a lot on his deathbed.
Said operation for the Bolivia,
assassins for operations,
40 were all there.
They were all there to watch the,
the big event.
They all collaborate and he says he's on his death.
But here's even,
he was there as a bomb.
He was one of the bumps.
We were all watching it.
There's a photograph of him,
there's a photograph of him from the arrest.
They arrested a bunch of Hobos.
I said,
getting off the top killers.
They were all assassins.
They were and they've identified some of the guys who were on that,
on that train.
One of them was a fucking the the actor.
The fuck's his name.
Woody Harrelson.
Harrelson.
Where do you house his dad.
His Dad was an assassin like legitimate,
like crazy and so he,
I would hunt on his death bed.
You can watch this at the library on you too.
He said he was,
he was bench warming.
He was,
there was a lot just in case something went wrong.
There was a bunch of people there.
He was getting shot.
He was getting lit up from all sorts of the Hobos were undercover cops?
No,
no.
The hobos were like,
at least one of the Hobos has been identified as a known so not just the hour
time,
but there's other guys that have like people have broken down the photos of the
Hobos and they said that that this guy is that guy,
this
guy,
an assassin.
Like what they weigh it,
it seems like they had done was they had planned to kill Kennedy and they
planned to do it in Dallas for some reason and they brought in a bunch of
different people to do it.
Now here's where it gets really squirrely.
When you find out how many people who are witnesses who testified that they were
there at the shooting wound up dying and really fucked up ways.
They wound up dying by murder.
They wound up dying and weird car accidents where they're fucking break lines
were cut.
There was a ton of them.
So many of them that they,
someone,
I think it might've been lifting as well.
David lifting the same guy who wrote best evidence.
They had some calculation on what the odds are of all these people meeting
violent demises inside of two years and it was crazy,
bro.
See if you could find that young Jamie from funnel.
No.
How many people see if the,
the the amount of people who witnessed the Kennedy assassination,
who wound up dying under mysterious circumstances.
Crazy shit.
Astronauts.
Aliens to one.
It's like a millions to one.
Like if you look at how many people died and what are the odds of them all like
getting murdered or killed suicide.
We are weird suicides,
you know,
like hang themselves on a fucking coat rack.
Like weird shit.
Yeah,
Jay,
the JFK story is deep as fuck.
They killed that guy,
buddy.
Everybody collaborated.
They all agreed we need to get rid of this guy.
See,
I'm surprised more guys as they get older than them,
their deathbed.
Don't tell the truth.
Nobody cares.
Here's the thing.
By then there is also plenty of fake stories are they have to do.
Look at it.
Here we go.
Here.
Look at this 101,000 trillion to one.
Some have claimed that a large number of witness,
an event have died.
Mysterious circumstances Sunday Times reported that the odds against these
witnesses being dead by February,
1967 or 100,000 trillion to one whoa
admitted he had made a careless journalistic mistake in his book,
a crossfire author Jim marrs provides a list of 103 people.
He claims died in mysterious circumstances between 63 and 76 in reality,
most of these people died of natural causes.
Some of these people did die in accidents.
Others were murdered or committed suicide.
However,
these people rarely had information that would have been important in helping
advance.
That sounds like an editorialization.
I want to know who's writing.
I think about it.
If you're going to pull off an assassination and then you're all going to go as
a group,
let's kill everybody around there as a matter.
That's hard to do.
That doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
I don't have pain.
I'm looking at that.
Right?
What I'm saying is what that guy wrote is an editorialization like that might be
correct,
but it might be wrong too.
He's making an assumption and he's writing this guest based on that assumption.
Wow.
I mean,
I don't know how you'd like,
okay,
so you've got all of those witnesses.
That's how fucking,
that's really hard.
Now you've got to organize all those markers.
Good luck.
All these different people that were witnesses.
Look at this.
Good.
Make that a little larger,
Jamie.
So I could read this shit like this.
They all die pretty spaced out that a lot of times they're talking to these,
oh,
these are all Kennedy's that were whacked.
Yeah.
Well everybody,
the Kennedys,
man,
they
were,
they started out killing the game.
So they start out as drug runners.
They were running moonshine.
That's how they started.
That's where they made their money.
Joe Deep.
And then JFK and,
and,
and uh,
the rest of his sons,
they started trying to change the world for real.
And they're like,
what do you mean happening?
Everybody wanted JFK died.
They knew.
They joked around about how they knew.
What they were trying to do is,
you know,
put their lives in jeopardy.
You know what's really interesting,
son?
Robert's son,
the way his son died on that plane.
You look into that holy shot.
That guy was coked up,
man.
He's coked up and didn't know what he was doing.
He was driving into the fog.
You have to be really look good.
You got to look into,
I did.
Did you really?
What do you think that he died?
He died with cocaine in his system and he didn't know how to drive the plot of
shady shit.
People,
people crash body,
they found a plain,
they found his body when people have Rekesh over a hundred murder,
suicides and mysterious deaths.
The strange fate of those who saw Kennedy shot for sure live,
he saw it.
See,
I'd have to,
I'd have to read all these pretty organized.
He's killed by a karate chop.
What's coming out?
Sign out.
I'm a patsy.
I'm being set up pop,
pop,
and then Jack Ruby shoots him on TV and this is Jim calmed was killed by a
karate chop to the throat as the emergency cashout there,
Jack Ruby killing.
That's what makes raises mind where I go,
why would Jack Ruby killed
and then just keep his mouth shut and go to jail.
What the fuck is that about?
That?
That's the part that I think is really super expert on JFK.
You know more than I do,
but I spent a lot of time on JFK as well.
I just,
you just,
you know,
I just let you talk,
but I know a lot about that and there's so much,
there's people,
these people that know way more than me,
only read a few people's books.
They guy that blows me away the most about JFK.
Who knows that he studies all the players.
All the mob guys involved is a guy named ride Dawson.
He's fucking JFK encyclopedia.
Dude.
He knows it's so deep.
It's like game of Thrones times 10
right?
It isn't just JFK,
Lee Harvey Oswald,
and maybe a couple other assassins.
It's so God damn deep.
Do you could spend a life,
a lifetime just studying all the names and how they're all connected.
It's crazy.
It's super vast.
Well,
it's unquestionably a mystery and the idea that it's not,
it's pretty ridiculous to me that that trial down Nice Greece,
that wouldn't happen if she had a nice karate.
Yeah.
Look at this.
She's fighting off her back here.
I heard you said I was far left to say,
you know,
I'm so not far left.
Oh,
I thought you were.
No,
no.
That's where all Hillary down.
No,
I don't believe in big government or anything.
I believe in small government,
Libertarian.
I'm,
I'm what I believe in.
Like just maximum personal freedom.
Small government.
Yeah.
Total transparency.
All that stuff.
Okay.
No,
I know you cause you thought because of the Hillary thing now that was just more
my anti Trump thing.
I used to,
I,
I don't like Hillary at all.
Okay.
The one,
either one of them
just say you now.
All right.
Um,
and by the way,
I don't care.
I heard somebody said,
why do people have an obsession with Kung Fu being real?
What are they still make these movies?
All people do stupid.
Like we know now what works.
And it seems like for a long time though,
stupid Kung Fu movies,
they died off in the UFC became really popular.
But the appeal of people who could just like magically make people fly from like
a touch to the chest and shit like that.
It's so romantic to us that we bring it back.
It was,
it was kind of before we could prove that staff member,
like what my,
I remember it,
first of all,
it was Asian,
right?
So it was just,
there was a mystery to being from China.
There was a mystery from being from Japan where it was it we didn't,
the languages are so different from,
from English.
So for us,
this idea that they had these secrets,
these,
these debt,
like touching things and pass your points and he was so wise and he was so quiet
and so humble.
We wanted that person to be,
to know.
So we all as human beings want mystery.
We had this,
what all this stuff.
It's about we all,
we all want to be part of a secret group.
We all want,
we want to be in the know all of us.
So when somebody is a master of Kung Fu and breaks,
boards can imagine if there's a
is
touch,
it will be hilarious.
Bruce movies were incredible.
Think about enter the dragon that changed people's entire lives as in they went,
I'm only going to learn karate and I'm going in that direction.
I'm gonna open a school.
My whole life is going to be that and you got to walk around with our control
was just head kicked.
Her ventricle.
Hey is on queer street right now.
She has hurt.
Oh,
oh she ate.
Oh Shit.
That head kick
and run.
How she has it to slip to oh boy.
She go wobbled.
Damn powerful shoot for that single.
Can guys wear skirts to,
yes,
I would look at the slides.
Capillaries to do the spartan style.
Oh,
you'd probably should start doing comes Donald flow loose kicking Melvin Manhoef
member when he used to wear this gladiator ones.
Those are the bad God shit.
He does everything hard man.
No was so scary.
There's videos of men who have hidden the pads and make you want to never hit
pads again.
Well how about this?
There's a hey of him playing like just Piñata with Robbie Lawler's legs.
That's the craziest thing.
When he was kicking.
Robbie Lawler is one that fine.
You know,
hit him back with one belt one?
I believe so.
I think so.
I think she's still doing the day.
I think he's kickboxing too.
I think he varies.
He goes back and forth.
So explosive it tour,
you know,
how's it the big kickboxing organization too.
So you know a Gaston Bolanos is going back and forth.
He did his MMA be BW with Dell belter and then he's going to do a kickboxing
fight with Bella tour in April
mount.
Uh,
would you say that um,
kickboxing get has more head trauma than boxing?
Yoga?
It does.
Huh?
Yeah,
I would think so.
I mean the,
the thing is if the kicks land the thing,
it's,
if there are only three rounds though,
right?
Well it depends.
Some of them are five championship rounds.
Um,
but the thing about like,
it depends if you're more Thai or kickboxing,
Muay Thai,
you're definitely getting hit in the head a lot with elbows caught though Joe
maybe I think it's not as goal straight get back.
Oh,
but it's true.
Begs off bitch Korez is fighting with everything.
She's got to see numbers.
I would like to see like actual impact numbers.
Oh she's not sure if that was not good.
The thing is,
the potential for getting neck kicked or head kicks ref is,
but then it's kind of overfishing go on.
Taking punishments.
True.
That's a good point.
Presenting the question is like what kind of head trauma we talking about?
We talking about one big bomb.
What's worse?
One big bomb or eating like 50,
triple g jabs.
50 triple g jabs.
What people die from usually like this rough a lot.
You think that's better than Nicole Gonzaga Cro cop.
Oh hundred percent dude.
That's cray is very tough.
You got to respect her,
her,
her heart here.
You got to,
do you remember when nobody thought that you'd ever see women fight like this?
I know like women fights were never really big and boxing.
I mean they kind of,
they're still not the gold medal winner.
She's awesome knowledge.
But you had a few that were like interesting.
Like Christy Martin and then there was um,
lay low,
see a Riker.
Lucier Ryko was probably one of the best female boxers.
Probably the best one ever.
And then Laila Ali,
because she was Muhammad Ali's daughter,
she got a lot of press Riker can hit like she was and then there's that other
girl to mia St John.
Remember her?
What about Christy?
What was your see Martin,
the coal miner's daughter back attack.
Powerful.
There's just not enough depth.
So the,
it never grows like one girl who dominates,
but then they just go a,
of course.
How did I forget Anne Wolf and wolf was probably the scariest knockout artists
waiting for women's boxing.
Oh,
she's phenomenal.
And that it's over and she's a sick coach too.
Amazing coach.
But you know what man,
it's just,
it never,
we never saw this many matchups like,
and you never saw this many match.
I was like,
the thing about boxing is you're only really going to see like maybe two fights,
maybe three.
If you're really going to watch a pay per view card.
Do you watch you sit through the whole card?
Do you,
cause if I watch a UFC and there's five fights in the main event,
like in the main car,
you're going to probably watch every fight and be pumped about it.
That's why UFC does well in the short amount of time has grown so much because
the five entertaining fight Jack,
do you know the people and the kid with Boxton like on the undercard of a Floyd
Mayweather fights usually shit like why is it like that?
Why not stack?
It was some good times man.
Well the UFC,
they saw the holes in boxing's promotion came and they capitalized on it.
This is the other thing.
Why I think women bigger than boxing,
this
shit bitch go,
hey is bridging on a changing on her chin.
But how much pressure are you allowed to apply?
Cause you can't strike with your head,
right?
You can't put all the pressure you want,
but can you batch,
you can backwards headbutted he can,
you know you can't have but,
but you could put any,
what do you do here when they had that weird though,
come on man,
you could head kick somebody's butt.
You can't backwards head buttom why can't you backwards?
Headbutt him backwards head.
But I feel like you should be able to do,
you can't hit button.
And you know what?
Let me start that league and that the tennis court.
Well make that happen.
Don't you feel like that?
You should be able to backwards.
How can we,
yeah,
we tennis court size.
We agreed on this way.
We know like there's something that accentuates the bigger than a basketball
court.
Um,
no,
no.
Basketball courts picker.
Oh by the tennis court is I believe a hundred feet.
Right?
How long?
How long is it,
what's bigger Jamie?
I think basketball is longer.
Tennis is wider.
Jamie.
People ask you questions in real life and ask you to pull that shit out.
Doing this.
My life
courts are 78 feet basketball courts in 94.
Okay,
so it was a little rain.
Get to the basketball game.
But here's the thing.
Do you think that you should be able,
if you,
if you're able to elbow someone in the face,
why can't you backwards head and someone going to die because you backwards head
butted somebody that knows.
Yeah,
add it.
The technique,
I feel like that's a real tank.
Tech head.
Bunch of BS percent headbutt hundred percent 100 the back of the head.
You know what I feel like if you don't ask
someone for a neck kick.
Okay.
If your neck kicking someone and you're getting them back here.
If a guy standing like this and you're coming over the top of the right kick,
you weren't hitting him in the back of the fucking head.
What do you think Brandon?
I'm cool with tech back here.
I'm cool with headbutts.
I'm not cool with,
if you have someone's back elbow in the back of the head just cause there's a
law,
there's not a ton of all fucking dangerous.
It's all at the back of the head can make you can go blind.
Very,
very vulnerable
because it's permanent damage to the eyeballs,
not my brain bro.
You're hitting the ball arenas on Indian reservations.
That's what we find out.
Those who were not to take this to Indians and the has got a lot.
I think I'm going to,
I'm not giving this to,
we watch this fight.
We barely watched this fight,
but the sin,
you gotta remember they're in the majority draw.
Whoa.
Oh Wow.
Well Marion is more excited.
She's happy and bitch go.
Hey has not little booty chap there.
See that?
Oh,
there it goes to the dance.
What is the mobile phase?
She got beat up,
but my is tough.
She's thick withdrawals.
Yeah.
Yes sir.
Boom Sir.
Um,
yeah,
so if we did it,
we'd have to do it on an Indian reservation.
Yeah.
What does the other one,
the one right there.
Um,
[inaudible] son.
Yeah.
Mohegan Sun.
We're going to have to go with a ton of stuff we can some bell toward.
Does a bunch of fights and reservations.
You don't have to test a basketball arena though on an Indian reservation.
That's,
let's not get greedy.
We can't.
The whole point is,
it's gotta be on a bath.
You build it.
They will come.
Let's just build one ourselves.
Caught the fight companion arena.
Well,
if you just have it in a basketball sized flat area at the bottom of their
arena,
they must have an arena.
If they're having these events.
Now you're talking about WCL,
the Chuck Norris Shifts.
You had one in there.
You just have that center area where you have that octagon spread it out by at
least another seven feet on each side.
Get rid of this mat it down.
Yeah.
Yeah,
Matt it down.
That's what that place was because this is a Olympic training center where the
had a lot of the Olympic stuff like wrestling and stuff like that,
so he could do that.
They're the only really issue.
The only real issue would be people storming the s the f,
the flat area where the people are competing.
Well,
you got to act like a Goddamn like they do and I do
wonder what you would be able to do to stop that though,
because the thing is if somebody wanted to charge octagon,
it's very,
there's a lot of steps.
Good like charging that,
huh?
Yeah.
I mean,
security might work,
but if there's actually like a mob basketball games,
if they just wanted a file out onto the court,
it could be,
it never happened.
The basketball happened once.
These are fighters,
they're savages.
No,
the crowd's not going to be savages.
Some nightclub in the audience and someone in the audit.
Do you remember when Anson anyway fought frank shamrock
and frank shamrock was,
is he fight hen center?
Egan.
Who did you fight and Tencent and he was,
that's right.
And he's beating him and they stopped the fight and YG and jumped into the ring
and started attacking Frank Shamrock when Frank Frank stopped answering with a
bunch of needs to face and then Egan jumped frank like now if that was a flat
area.
Yeah,
and not,
not like a,
it could be a me laying,
it can be chaos.
Oh,
he talking about royal rumble and then you got to charge more with basketball.
A lot of times at the end,
people run on the court calls.
Never Mba.
Mba,
you can't get on the court security.
I don't think that's going to be a problem.
Many of them.
I think that,
you know what,
we've got to just trash to plan ahead.
We got bigger fish to fry fish.
The bigger fish forgiveness thing,
sanctioned buying a stadium.
We go to,
we go to somewhere that's conservation.
You could make your own rules at any of her as restoration,
right?
Maybe they changed.
No,
we can.
They can.
They can do whatever the fuck they want to pay them.
A nice royal.
They have crazy rules like here's the thing that they,
that drives some people nuts.
They can hunt whatever they want whenever they want a hunted and they can do
whatever method they want,
like the Indians and Canada that you spotlights to hunt Moose.
They shine at night on the Moose.
The Moose don't know what the fuck's going on.
Boom.
They blast him from the back of Atvs.
They do all this different shit that you're not allowed to do.
If you're a regular person,
you're like,
dude,
you say,
yeah,
but if you're a ne,
I mean it doesn't matter if you're white.
If you're a black guy,
you're not allowed to do it.
I'm saying if you're not one of the first natives,
it made the call the first nation.
First nation.
Yeah.
I was total sorta,
whoa bro.
He's a thing like how far are we going back?
Because it wasn't their land when it was covering two miles of ice.
Okay.
That was just 10,000 years old once land.
But exactly.
So who's to say that like human land?
Well,
who knows how it was set out?
Who knows who conquered who to establish their domain in that like to share
before,
before anybody who is,
you know,
try not before the native Americans,
but no,
not for the native Americans.
Native Americans were here from fucking Siberia,
but established too.
They all gone,
you're right.
But they all wandered here.
See,
the thing is they know exactly.
That's the,
the reality is we are feeling terrible as people that inherited this beautiful
place called Los Angeles from some barbarians that at one point in time took it
from some other people that were here first.
I mean,
that's really what oil bad for the dinosaur.
It doesn't have anything to do with the people that are there right now.
That's my point.
The people that are in those reservations right now,
they didn't get anything stolen from them and they were born in 1968 you know
what I'm saying?
It's like the whole thing is squirrely that you're allowing them to have
casinos.
They gonna have cage fights,
negative rooster fights with fucking nuclear weapons attached.
Their beaks.
Ian's allowed to crosswalk with just like flashing and ID.
They don't get checked or anything like that.
I'd wonder,
I don't know.
Mexico,
India,
Canada and the states and into Mexico back and forth.
It's,
it is.
It's really odd that they're allowed to just have casinos and just,
and they also make partnerships with people who aren't native,
you know?
And then those guys profit off these casinos too.
It's like you get a stipend from the government.
Yeah.
Shit.
Load of money.
I did a,
I did an appearance at an Indian reservation.
They were bawling.
Is the Beverly Hills of Indians.
There's all that too.
From the fucking ankles up.
Full body tattooed.
Isn't it crazy too that you still call them Indians?
Like that was a mistake like they were supposed to be.
They thought they were in India.
These dumb motherfuckers
definitely,
this is not India native Americans,
but they're not even David and I are native American or sue or tropical
heat test parkin until Comanche Apache.
But there were some Pueblo,
there was some amazing,
amazing people and they did some incredible shit or some savages.
What does this say?
Once you have proven that you are at least 50% aboriginal blood,
uh,
if you were born in Canada,
if you have at least 50% aboriginal blood,
you may be entitled to certain rights and he's right.
You can cross the US Canadian border freely can live and work in the u s wow.
Be Eligible for public benefits such as Medicaid,
supplemental
security income,
medicare or unemployment benefits and other public assistance.
Proven,
provided you meet the appropriate agency guidelines.
You could register for college or university in the United States as a domestic
student rather than a foreign student.
Wow.
Interesting.
Yeah,
man,
you do not have to register for the military.
You do not have to obtain a work permit.
You do not have to be processed for an alien registration card.
Also known as green card.
The U s government cannot deport you.
They cannot exclude you from entry and they cannot deny you services and they
run shit doe.
Does anyone have any Indian Indian in him?
You have to have 50% a Mohawk t mobile arena reserves.
June 10 for Mayweather.
Mcgregor,
good.
Zoobilee it's fucking happening.
How is that going to happen?
What do you mean?
How do you think the UFC and were there come to an agreement?
Yes.
That's what's happening in Conoco's
is in cahoots with the UFC.
Let's get,
I guarantee you you'll see is involved,
but the report,
who knows who made that report pretty legit hit it on the way over here.
I made a,
I might have.
I think it's going to happen man.
Wow.
You really think so.
I really do and you're asking me to come to in it so let's just figure this out
and how you want to talk to you do
probably companion.
I don't know man.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Well,
if you're not commentating,
we need to do like giant companion for it.
And that was celebrate the shit out of it.
I would prefer that.
Honestly,
June 10th June 10th it's about to get a lot of my man Mayweather throws you that
TMT money.
Hmm.
I don't think they really care about me commentating.
They'd probably want Max Kellerman or of the boxing people.
Max Kellerman you it would be fun.
I would love to do it with them,
but that's what I,
that's,
that's boxing match.
You know,
that's their world has been,
if it was an MMA match though,
and he was sitting down next to me doing commentary,
you know that,
I think that would be a little odd to not,
not a Floyd was just doing boxing the octagon.
You know what I'm saying?
You need can be an awesome,
well no,
no,
no.
I'm saying if the roles were reversed,
I think you could talk about moving Connor's history cause they,
they're not giving a shit.
Let's be real.
They're going to be like,
you know Shannon Sharpe talking about UFC.
It's tough to listen to.
It's going to be good at someone who's knowledgeable.
Breakdown like commerce history,
how he came here.
He got his movement.
What he's known for.
I think that's super important.
You have to have people who don't watch UFC.
Yeah cause you're getting a shit load of new boxing.
You know it sounds bad.
It's tune in,
hanging out with you guys.
Smoking weed,
watching it right here.
That's how it's so much better.
I just want my dear friend Joe Rogan,
part of the biggest fight of combat and history.
I'm good.
I'd like to see a big deal right here.
Cause you don't think that's the biggest fight in his life.
The biggest fight in history bigger than Ali Frazier number wise.
Yeah.
It's a big paper view ever because it brings in two worlds.
It brings in the UFC world and this one guy who was unquestionably the biggest
star in the UFC,
unquestionably by a long shot,
and then you bring in a guy has been
one of the biggest money makers in the history of boxing game,
the only guy to go 49 and no others in rocky Marciano.
I mean,
he's like right there and we'd love to break rocky Marciano's record and then
you know what man,
when people want to do things like break someone's record and you want to do it
so bad that you take on a guy who's never had a boxing match before and then
that guy starches you,
me.
I mean,
it's not like that.
I'm going to build a shrine to him,
pray to whatever it is.
Some of them,
man,
I'm telling you,
there's something about that dude.
He's got something going on.
Magic.
He's got a little something extra special,
but he would need,
he would need everything to line up.
It would have to be the McGregor Mayweather.
It would have to dismiss him as a threat.
He'd have to not train hard enough,
hit up to not seriously consider the possibility that Connor connects on him and
knocks him out.
Right.
And then kind of would have to do some rough housing.
He would have to hold it and get clench.
He'd have to hold them and hit 'em.
You'd have to try to get off as many shots and bullying around and wear him out
to a possibility.
It's a possibility.
He's a much bigger mass.
He's a much bigger man.
Yeah,
very,
very quick.
But if you compare the two of them frame wise,
like what if they ever do do it and they're standing right at each other looking
down at each other,
you know,
do an eye to eye.
You're going to go,
oh shit.
Yeah.
Connor's way.
Because you remember when Eddie Alvarez was going Idi with Connor and you
realize how big Connor's head is.
He like Jesus,
just a bigger dude cause I'm shoulders,
his legs.
He's a big fuck.
I mean he could make that 145 pound cut when he's on death's door,
but may whether it makes it easy,
what are they going to fight at 45 that's a good question.
No,
maybe there was fighting at one 54 his last two fights.
I bet they do it like 55 or 60 maybe.
Maybe it depends on what may was comfortable with it,
but I think the,
in Dana Light,
you want to be part of that fight.
If you're Dana let you want to be in cahoots with all these guys with
Mayweather,
Floyd,
or don't want the fight to take place at all and book.
He's got the,
he got fucked because number Grumet off,
got sick,
making that weight.
If number get Madoff didn't get sick,
Then neuroma Madoff and Tony Ferguson,
Dana White did.
Oh No,
the UFC did because look,
the real fight is the winner of her.
Tony Ferguson and Habib number,
good metal in the UFC.
Right.
So that's the real fight is like being a big challenge for Conor and that could
be a million plus papers.
The purest.
Right.
Especially if you,
if you either have that fight or the better fight financially is another fight
with Nate Diaz.
No,
the better fight financial is may with Oh yeah,
for box for sure.
The same for common or no,
for sure.
For sure.
Connor has a business that's by far the HUD 100% agree with what I was saying in
20 million weigh more than a hundred million.
A hundred by a hundred.
100 million each to Ray Borg.
Looks good as far he does.
He's so fast.
Um,
w w well they a Khabib and Tony are going to fight again though,
right?
Aren't they?
But here's the thing that makes a bead might be able to make that weight
and,
and you know,
since Kelvin miss wait a couple of times and Dana forced him to fight it,
one 85,
I mean,
it makes sense to Dana goes,
dude,
you got to do one 70 at least once or twice,
but we'll go up in weight to fight him.
Well,
he only mess wait once,
twice,
twice.
Tonia huge.
55 minutes again against anybody's tall,
but he's not.
He's like Tony is like five ten five 11 okay.
Tony's built perfect for the division.
Yes.
Tom Freed up 50 he's got,
he's got a lot of muscle.
Even though he's long.
He's very strong.
He's excellent in the clinch.
I was looking forward to that fight so much.
My heart,
my how big it could be.
It could be got a huge frame.
It's a tank.
No,
he doesn't have a nutritionist.
He doesn't talk.
He's not,
you're not being professionals.
He's thick.
Could you hear what Tony Tony to get done and wondering when they're like doing
media?
Yeah.
And it could be with saying something like,
why do you get your sunglasses on?
It's like 26 seven lunches and he's like,
good luck or that weight cut.
Yeah,
I hear him breathing cause your cardio sucks.
I said,
cause your cardio sons,
that's a Tony said to him,
do they have to make it at 55 because what do you do with that fucking bet?
That interim title
fight Floyd.
What?
We can't just fucking hang up at defy.
But don't you think that that's the fight that has to be made in that division,
right?
That's the right tone.
If it's,
but if he can't make one 55 can,
he needs to get real and get a fucking die?
I don't know what happened to him.
We don't eat Tiramisu the week of.
I know that he did that corn on embedded and Tony even tweet out like for sure
when fucking eat Tiramisu,
he really ate Tiramisu.
It was on an embedded video.
Whoa.
That's how he smelled it.
He was like,
have fun making weight.
Why are you helping him?
Puffin,
did you have to make that fight and to be,
you can do it.
He's just,
he's made it before,
but we don't know what happened when he had to go to the fucking hospital.
They said he was in massive pain.
Like we also know he'd be like,
hold on a second day.
Luke Rockhold you're right.
But Luke Rockhold said something.
There was some quote that I had read.
God Damn it.
What did it see?
What,
what they said about what,
what did,
uh,
bebes corner list as the official issue that was happening to him.
He was six pounds overweight,
right?
Yes.
When he went to the hospitals.
And that's,
that's huge.
That's so heavy.
You're so heavy when your body's your body shutting down,
like you're six pounds away and your body is shutting down.
Come in the week of the fight.
Yeah.
But obviously fucked up with his,
uh,
his discipline if he's eaten Tiramisu.
If that's true,
that's even more disappointing.
Maybe you just had a bite,
but either way you don't have a,
and I'm not saying it's the answer.
You don't have a mic dolce or one of these guys who are helping you with your
diet.
Right.
Tony's up and wait to find them.
It makes sense.
Can make sense for Tony.
It makes sense for Tony mean who wants to fight this guy?
But for the division,
it's so weird.
It's like,
well,
what is,
it sucks the division.
What is this guys?
The whole
fights bigger than what the division looks like.
That fight,
that fight needs to happen.
I agree too.
I agree.
I agree with that.
That has all this other shit's going on.
Mayweather and Garner,
all this other shit.
It's the GSP.
Bisping windows.
Here it goes.
Medical,
he says a weight loss,
weight management,
medical issues.
He was treated and it's been discharged.
That doesn't say what the issue is.
This the official us.
See,
see if you could find out.
I feel like I read an article that was interviewing Luke Rockhold.
Rockhold was talking about what happened to the [inaudible] Dot Gov you see Dana
though?
He goes,
if you,
if you were to,
we maybe could assist drinking.
Who gave him a beer?
This isn't beer.
What is it
that bear fruit?
So someone gave the Gremlin water after men.
No,
but Dana was saying he panics.
He goes,
oh
well I got a coffee cherry.
You can't leave a guy drinking by himself.
That was the moment the wheels fell off the podcast.
Okay,
here it is.
This is what I read.
Habib wasn't getting any blood to his liver.
This is what Luke Rockhold says.
Look,
that is fucking real bad.
So scroll down and let's,
let's see what Luke,
it says the weight cut wasn't going very well.
Could be,
was complaining about a pain in his side and we had to cut short the weight cut
and sure enough it gets worse over night and had to go to the hospital.
Unfortunately this is the fight is really fucking four Bababa from what I
understand,
he wasn't getting any blood to his liver and something went wrong with his
weight cut.
It's very similar to his last fight.
What I understand and just something went wrong.
You never know what these weight cuts,
I guess,
but I think he's ready to go and we can rebook this.
What is,
he was wrong.
No,
he's a training partner.
He's a Aka a hundred pounds heavier training partner.
Yeah.
Well from the same gym.
Yes.
I mean it obviously ain't a hundred pounds.
He's a big walk around that.
It could be shit.
I Dunno.
I don't want to misspeak.
I'd assume high seventies yeah,
it looks like it.
Right?
And he ain't fat.
No,
they gotta make that fight,
man.
That's the fight.
I'd say that's the Madison.
If there'd been when the fight fell through,
like when John and chill thing.
I really wasn't that math.
There's been other fights.
Uh,
John D C I wasn't that upset.
This one.
I was pissed man.
I was really upset telling me what fine his camp,
everything was perfect.
It was on such a good fighter.
Now tell me,
um,
if you're allowed to speak about this,
I don't know if you are,
but there's been a lot of complaints about his pay.
Like what,
what,
what exactly did happen if you could clarify what you were training him.
I don't know the specifics.
Uh,
cause I heard he was very upset that whatever and reading was that he was very
upset that he wasn't even getting show money.
I'm just going to say like,
if it's,
uh,
if you,
if you were getting 10,000 to show 10,000 to,
and
you made weight and your opponent doesn't make wait,
just give them the show money.
It's 10 k,
but when it's like big money and your opponent can't make weight than we're not
going to give you the whole host.
All that money.
Kind of like that.
I feel like it should be insured and that's why it's confusing to me.
Then I totally down,
I don't know exactly what,
and I know there was that issue.
Will he still get that show money?
I don't know if he got it or he got half or something like that.
I don't really like,
I don't really get into it with
Tony.
Tony's right on that cause he did all the necessary steps.
You went through training camp.
It's not his fault.
Could beep didn't fucking make,
he suffers from it.
You can't have that.
If a fighter doesn't make the other fighters should be,
I'm not sure.
Sure.
Maybe.
Maybe it was,
maybe it was a deal like this or something.
I don't know,
but maybe it was a deal.
We can get you to 50 to show and on whatever to win or something like that.
Some big,
but we're offering that.
If the fight happens,
if for some reason your opponent in small print at,
doesn't that make the fight,
you're not going to get that show money.
It's like if the fight happened,
I feel like maybe after,
you know,
UFC would be smart on their end to structure some of them.
They need a guarantee.
Guarantee person you'd
see better.
Five feel like you need to make a person who does not make the weight get a
loss.
That's what I think fucking insane.
Feel.
It gets a loss.
And I feel like there's no fight and I feel like the other guy gets paid.
There's only one way to stop it.
You've got to punish people.
Tony's going to make it.
Yes,
but you know,
we gotta make it a loss because the fighter didn't make weight.
Correct.
Why do you have four glasses there?
One drink?
No,
no,
no.
Here's,
you already had a beer gremlins.
You remember the movie?
He give the little cute things.
Water Callen determine the devils.
You fucking up.
This goes into chem trails and operation funder foot 85 people.
Once he takes that,
and we started talking about Kennedy and who did it,
did it,
did it.
Meanwhile,
we're not even watching this awesome Ray Borg fight.
He's one of the few flyweights in this division that like is a real interesting
candidate for fighting mighty mouse.
And for me it was a tough motherfucker man.
People just write him off cause he also got destroyed by Dj.
But number three in the world really doesn't lose just djs.
Just something special was just CJ.
If you're listening,
you got to do super fights.
I'm sick of seeing you find it that way.
You,
we got to move on then Dominick Cruz,
do you hate money?
I don't know what it is,
man.
but I feel like,
um,
I want to see him clean out that division.
Keep cleaning it and just keep doing it.
Look,
I think you,
me and 75,000 other people are watching this.
Plenty of fights for Dominick Cruz or anybody else at one 35.
Between Cody Garbrandt,
Tj Dillashaw.
Um,
I'm lean Linacre is much less attractive out Dillashaw exposed him dealer shop
pretty much kind of clowned him.
God Damn Dillashaw was good enough to me till a shawl.
Gar Brant,
what do you think happens in that fight?
That's big.
Tell you what,
man,
I would've had one opinion of what would happen in that fight before the cruise
fight and before,
uh,
before Cody fought Cruz,
but after co co he fought Cruz.
He looks so fucking good.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
he's good.
It's like a tank.
Like a tank is fast as fuck.
His boxing is laser beam accurate and he's getting better and it wasn't better
all the time.
He's getting better.
He outclass dom and then you see you can't do that.
I'm math but I'm going to do it right yet.
Dom and Tj was a battle something.
Tj One,
I don't know man.
I just feel like government,
he's,
he's like a little chuck Ladell of that weight class.
Like he lance,
you're fucking in trouble.
I thought your podcast with Dominic was amazing.
I really have so much respect for that guy.
So he's so intelligent about sorta fighter's mind and dealing with injuries.
But his injury,
like the amount of injuries he's had to deal with are crazy.
Like,
like the 10 pulling off his heel and I mean in the fight crazy shit you guys
have by flags.
Just let her beautiful.
Oh man,
this fight is fucking hot.
Man For Eagle.
Landed a beautiful leg.
Chicken Ray board came back with a leg kick of his own in a spinning back fist
behind it.
I'd like board to do the,
when the boards of bad motherfucker.
He's a a bow hunter.
Big Time.
Uh,
just one of the things he Paul,
yeah,
he pulled,
he after his fight,
he uh,
called out,
uh,
John Dudley,
you just wanted to set,
I wanted to be on your podcast and I want to go bow hunting with you.
So bow hunting fanatic.
Damn.
Yeah.
GCA.
He doesn't get enough credit because that in Brazil doing thing and he's small,
Dj barely gets enough credit.
So all these guys,
it's a tough go for them.
It's a tough go.
The whole division chair just needs to,
I think start doing super fights.
Give you the teacher,
give them dumb.
Let's do crazy though.
That like 35,
he's got so much hype behind it and 25 has almost none because we just don't
care about those tiny,
tiny guys.
10 pounds difference.
She in 25 and 35 of them are funny.
They are so small.
As long as it's someone smaller than you will pay attention.
It's like we know what we need as a straw weight,
men's division and then Dj,
I'd be like,
he's a little motherfucker fucking these little tiny 115 pounds.
I just,
I don't know what djs waiting for for the,
maybe they're not offering him or whatever.
He's got it.
Wilson has in his next fight and after the Wilson fight,
like then what do we do now?
Who's born don't the new owners,
if you don't,
the new owners of the UFC have the power to create stars.
They don't,
they like heartless Hollywood.
Well got to win.
No,
you don't have to be undefeated.
It's not,
not saying you just have to be at Paige vanzant blow up personalities.
You know,
just,
you need a small part of it.
The smaller girls now it's hurt him in TV show fighter personality.
It has to be there.
You know,
like people have got to be able to talk to you take him there and we just
haven't seen it yet.
Well,
Dj has got a fun personality.
He's great on podcasts.
He's a fun dude.
It's just people for whatever reason,
haven't you?
I appreciated what they're seeing.
Chocolate seat in in the inbox and they think he's,
if you talked to any boxing,
he's the best in the world.
He fights on triple g's card.
The paper you I think is next weekend.
Does anyone now for Miga?
I think Tj is the most exciting.
What a scrabble.
Oh Shit.
Ray Borg all over it.
Look at this.
Who's grabbing 20 fibers are mad dogs,
man,
the pace is so insane.
I don't you think that Tj is the most exciting fight?
Tj,
Tj Dillashaw no,
no,
definitely no.
He's decided to watch,
but he's mostly,
he's sliding past.
He's definitely one of Orthodox.
He's just so,
I mean I see Cody Garbrandt,
Dominick Cruz,
she rumble Johnson.
Yeah,
but I'm saying exciting like,
cause it just,
he's from angles and just movements and I dunno man.
He's just,
Oh,
he's access pace.
Great.
As far as the most,
one of the best in the world,
there's no doubt about it.
And if he can beat Cody.
He's in my pound for pound top five hours and I think he was when he beat Barao
the second time I was like,
well,
make an argument for someone who's higher up the top
high level off the cage.
That back tag,
it took that back and immediately went to the body triangle was squeeze.
Everybody does that now.
Everybody goes to the squeeze,
especially with their camp.
Think about it.
He's with Aldo and Barao.
Yeah.
It's crazy that that was a rare move.
The body triangle was a rare move taking the Dobie in the late nineties that's
true body.
It's pretty rare up until Ivan salivary did it and I didn't start doing it and
putting it into my game heavily until John John came back from Abu Dhabi and I
felt like,
why did you keep doing a triangle cross?
I can kept holding him like that because he never really did that in class.
He's just straight hooks and they said,
man,
so greased so much grace,
they're slipping so I got to lock their hips slipped down and that's all I need.
When John Jack says something,
you just to pretty much bank on it and that's the way to go.
He's ever told me to do and he kind of direction.
He's pointed me in.
Boom,
I go right to know who I bet has the most body lock time in the UFC and you can,
I don't know who would track it.
I would bet Anderson Silva does.
When you think about with Travis Luder,
Dan Henderson,
that mother fucker spends a ton of time there.
A ton of you think about his flights when they go to the ground.
It's so hard to get out of man.
I've never seen anybody get out of it.
Did he get Travis looters back?
Yes.
Triangle triangle that remembered it from the bottom.
You're working here.
Travis mounted him.
I know,
but it's exhausting.
It's hard to breathe and stuff.
Dude,
that was my best example for the longest time of a guy that was on death's door
was Travis when he didn't make weight for the Anderson Silva fight a title fight
the triangle.
Yup.
And also being a really tiny guy and sweaty as fuck and the third round with two
minutes left.
These guys move so fast and they don't get fucking tired.
That's just crazy.
All Day.
The game is so different for them.
Must they get tired too,
man,
like I remember when Alibaba routine off od a Dj and Dj outworked him.
Then it turns out that he was all,
if you're one 25 around Epl,
probably not for you.
That's probably of the game for a board.
Gets landed some big shots right here.
Wait,
Borg is no joke,
man,
but neither is for me.
No.
For me to get to know.
These are hard.
He brought,
he busted his face also Sanderson,
Travis looter triangle and them shit and he's gay.
He's holding the back of his neck.
He's letting them have that arm bar.
Look at that.
He's letting them have that left arm.
He should swing.
He's holding onto his neck.
That's how Randy couture got armbar against the ensign just holding all that
neck and he's not doing it anymore.
It's fine right there too.
He has it.
It's open.
He should be swinging.
Just came off him.
Ooh.
Oh Shit.
He went for it.
At least he's out of that spot.
Got To give this to book.
This is torque.
Immediately goes back to the Black Mountain.
Wow.
Glory.
His transitions and those fucking elbows from the top position are so scary.
Dude from Megan.
I'm trying right arm triangle right there.
He should just close it off.
Was arms on under yet?
He could have just put it there,
right?
But the other guys got risk control so you can slide them out.
Oh scramble.
He still has it right there and he still has that opportunity for them to turn
the twister pass free the knee and then slice to three quarter mount just like
Dan.
But this speed of these exchanges is what you're really supposed to be looking
for in him.
Oh,
he's going for it.
He's going through the choke.
There it is.
Five seconds lab and it's got to go for it.
A tough guy to chunk.
Wow.
These guys at this weight class are so fucking amazing.
Like this is what MMA supposed to be.
It's supposed to be like movements without any physical limitations.
You know,
like you just can't move at this pace if you weigh 300 pounds.
But,
but also at that,
you know,
at heavyweight,
the lighter weights,
the reason why we like it,
because it can end at any given moment.
These chansom getting finished aren't great.
Yeah.
I mean,
except for Cody who knocks guys out with one shot.
I want the linen person.
Yeah.
One 35 well then I also was wanting,
I mean,
djs knocked out a few people at 25 and he knocked out Benevidez one pond.
But the reality is it's way more rare that weight class to see like a one shot
Kao and that's why it's not as big as would a draw.
Yeah.
But it's also why those guys exchanged many more techniques.
They're not gonna be able to finish the other off with one shot.
So everybody's much more technical oriented,
more Korean.
Cool.
Yeah.
You have to be like,
if you look at these two guys and these scrambles,
they're so technical.
If you had the skills that heavyweight or two or five,
it's either of these guys,
you'd be the greatest fall.
My Gosh.
Imagine if there was a fucking heavyweight that move like Ray Borg.
That would be insane.
Be Scared,
Bishop.
Greatest of all time.
Yeah,
like Ray Borg is a top 10 contender for sure,
but he hasn't got a shot at the title yet.
He was a heavyweight.
If you've got to,
if he was a heavyweight to be the greatest of all time.
If you want to,
if there's anybody who,
who's like,
if there are any athletes in the other sports who have that kind of explosion
speed.
Dexterity.
Yeah,
but like,
like take,
take a Westbrook,
Russell Westbrook,
if he'd strange MMA,
if he had trained MMA,
like you know,
since he was 17 it's a chance he could be a guy that big with that kind of
speed.
They're out there,
they're just not interesting.
You Punch in the face where they can make way more money playing football and
shooting them and also they probably started doing that sport when they were a
little kid.
You've got amazing at it.
Transfer over an MMA in 20 years.
We'll see it will,
you'll see a guy like that.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Maybe not the heavier weights.
They're going to have to want to do it.
That's the thing.
I mean he's going to have to bring the parents to do it.
To encourage the Johnson could play NFL fee.
No,
not right now,
but if he,
if he played football in high school and in College Board has got the frame and
the,
and the height he'd be safe to,
he'd be a safety.
It's a lot of speculation.
That's like saying Ray Lewis was a kickboxer.
He'd be a world champ,
but what I'm saying is you guys are talking about these athletes.
We already got a feel of it.
Yeah.
John Jones.
John,
John.
No,
John Jones can,
no,
no.
John Jones wouldn't be professor nail their sport.
Isn't that funny?
Ask him about it.
He ran the 40 he ran like a four nine or five flat.
He,
his brothers is not going to hand.
His brothers are beast.
She comes my same skills.
It's just,
dude,
it's hard to compare it.
Apples and oranges,
but it's same.
It's the same.
You know he's so athletic,
right?
John?
John,
we're fighting.
Yes,
but that trend then fell.
No.
Well you know what man,
I don't know.
How much time do you dedicate towards that?
How much time does it dead court dedicate towards wrestling and MMA primer on a
40 or let's just say a sprint.
If you went against the guy who was,
he weighed 220 pounds.
If you just ran a sprint against division one football guys smoking the shit out
of him.
That's just,
that's pure athleticism.
But if you played football,
maybe puts on a lot of muscle and a lot of ways lower defensive and you don't
have to be that fast play in these days.
You do at the end.
How far can they,
how do they run for seven forties yeah,
Shit's of Linemen Watch 300 290 pounds when the four six the at the end,
those guys are freaks.
They just had a 370 pound guy,
Ron a four seven 43 70 do you see this?
This is [inaudible] 74 standing next to that guy,
Jamie looked that guy,
if he's have linemen three 70 he ran a four salmon McCardle did.
It's crazy.
Think about what that would feel like dealing with,
think about what that would feel like to be on the field or that guy runs by
you.
That's what he was MVP.
Look at these elbows.
But I mean if you could stand there like right next to him as he's sprinting,
just let them run by Sega is feel
the force whole different thing of almost 400 pounds running faster than you
ever could hope to.
Yeah.
Scary.
Launching his entire body down the track.
They find that guys who are that big and that fast actually ended up getting
injured faster.
So bigger and faster in the NFL according to fight or sports science.
Uh,
Nice.
Not always better because you get injured faster.
Well I would imagine there's soft tissue could only take so much debate.
They're talking about like the biggest guys.
Yeah,
apparently they did a thing where like you get huge dudes who are really fast
and somehow they don't last as long as somebody who is,
because it's physics.
Right.
So because your body can only take so much.
Yeah.
It depends on the position and depending on the guy for sure.
Well it's also the sport itself is so fucking ruthless on your body.
I mean it just breaks you the injury,
the injury rate is 100% or something.
Somebody that somebody said that like in the NFL,
like everybody's injured injury.
I had an area and foster on the podcast this week and one of the things he said
is like,
if my kids wanted to play football,
I'd be like,
fuck that.
You know,
playing football.
And he goes,
I didn't bust my ass to get to this position to watch you do that shit.
Yeah.
He's,
you can see how it says that that guy was a freak done.
He's a freak.
He's amazing fucking monster.
He's amazing.
Super Freak.
And he was like,
I'm tired of it.
And foster.
He led the league in Russian for a lot of years.
And yeah,
he,
he was tired because he wanted to,
like,
he had a bunch of injuries and he was like,
this is not,
I don't want to do this.
He's only 30,
right?
Yup.
He's young primary command.
So this fucking prime right now.
30 and he decided I'm done.
Smart for running back you that it's time to go.
He's a smart dude.
He's not like,
he's not completely motivated by money.
He just,
he's not motivated by fame.
He also got paid.
So it's easy to say that one aid plenty in the bank.
He's hanging back.
But he's also being smart about being paid,
you know,
he doesn't have like $500,000 worth of jewelry on him.
You know,
he's not being an asshole.
You wonder what Lebron James would be like in the heavyweight division.
Like too big.
It's too big to 65 he could get down and he's 63 he's lead.
How much does he weigh?
Uh,
no.
I think Melbourne's to 50 now.
Two 53 something like chat look like he,
he'd gotten some weird diet.
Less a lot of ways.
Would you say Jamie?
I was saying it as an older guy now he's Kinda a little bit thinner it,
it's like two 52 40 best all time.
The Bron James,
he's a kilo kid.
I don't know if he officially,
but he has his picture comes up when you kind of Google something like that and
just all the time the Brown,
the Brown.
No,
Michael Jordan still better.
Oh yeah.
What does he have to do to surpass him?
Nothing.
There's nothing happening.
What?
The ones like five more championships still?
No,
because you know why?
Because he only wins championships when he forms these super teams.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's a bitch.
Bulls had a super team to man Pippin and all those guys.
Yeah.
But at the time Jordan was still a beast,
you know,
like he didn't ask for all that stuff and they drafted these guys.
It wasn't like,
he was like,
oh magic,
come play with me.
Here's Jordan
didn't do,
he didn't want to ring until,
what?
The sixth year,
seventh year or something like that.
Yeah.
It's still a monster though.
You know better
dude,
that is on the cheek.
That is 100% he'll to cheek hundred percent healed to cheat.
What's his name?
Who was with the red hair?
Thought Felder.
He's a bad ass.
Is he still that's worse than me.
No,
no,
no.
Can see what the one with with Terry Edom,
it just looks like it's not as bad because he stiffens up and on impact.
Its head doesn't snap back but it's cause he was dad and to those showed again
dead so on from the,
from the impact of the heel to the shake.
So muscular live for it.
It was horrible.
If you watched a video of him getting wheeled kicked in the back,
you see Ari,
Ari stands up like this.
Like you said,
he could see the wheel kick land and Ari's in the background probably on acid.
What do you watch this 10 this is the mega athletes.
He was an at three sevens.
Their guy was three Oh seven ran out of sub five.
Does she just this the size of three Oh six and he ran a four six five,
six pounds.
316 they ran or what?
Four six five.
Oh my God.
Again,
watch this.
Watch this.
Can I do this?
This is the Saturday.
What position is this guy?
Gonna plug my mole line.
He'll be tackle.
Hey,
what?
Uh,
what called you from June to say that's a weird symbol.
Holding maybe.
Maybe it was three Oh seven nine three three 76.
Holy Shit.
Was this recent?
Toronto's was a couple of years ago now.
There was a guy who recently did some crazy shit.
That's incredible.
I had six wide receivers speed at 300 pounds.
Yeah.
Now think about this.
Look at him.
He should play defense.
Fuck that offense.
He could,
they could use his speed on defense playing an offensive lineman.
You don't need speed that
what'd you snuck?
Mafia?
He,
it would it be,
he could play middle linebacker at that.
With that speed.
Imagine him right there in the middle.
Some guy ran the fastest.
Whenever I think right.
The shaft,
two to two.
And how about this?
You know,
if he,
if he broke the record,
well,
Adidas gave this challenge to go.
Anyone who breaks the record,
they're going to give you an island of your choice and $1 million,
but you have to do an Adidas.
This whole brand in Nike.
So he didn't get it.
So sad they were going to give them an island.
Oh,
fucking island.
Off The coast of Japan or some shit.
Nah,
he could pick.
It was like five different islands.
They asked to when it,
dude,
you could want an island because I don't know about it.
I can't swim so I don't care.
Well,
right.
Is that how are on a boat and I can't swim.
Just give me the money.
No,
give me an island.
Whose Bisbing the cold GSP.
That's right.
Come on son.
These things you're eating.
These are backpack from meals.
I got the guy who was coming on my podcast.
It's um,
it's called a green belly meals and they have like a ton of calories.
I was going to say a ton of calories.
If you're hiking,
it's got a ton of carbs in it too though.
These are not,
these are non Kido.
This isn't going to take some exogenous ketones afterwards.
But um,
if you just have like half of it,
you're good.
Half of it as 25 grams and we going to shit my pants.
It was like $1,000.
No it's not.
But it's very dense,
very dense and heavy perform tonight at the comedy store.
Backpackers like to take these things with them because they're,
um,
they're really nutrient dense and there um,
yeah,
there's a bunch of the back third of the,
um,
did he go into the back?
Going to the,
to the,
to the room.
I'll go one third.
Daily nutrition,
protein,
calories,
fiber,
fats.
I don't know why.
We just don't know where that God damn pizza sometimes.
You know,
and I agree with you.
I just don't know how Tapioca Sarah was.
The first ingredient.
Can't eat into the mic.
We can't have cheese in your fucking
what if you're eating?
You're not talking.
I know we can't have that.
That's,
or maybe we have it delivered Africa,
Africa.
I ain't eating them
cranberry almond.
Ooh,
that's pretty tasty.
Yeah,
that's just an ad for green belly meals.
I'll just tell you right now,
I have no affiliation with these people who's not an advertisement.
I don't make any money from it.
I bought it.
I paid for it with American money,
American mark about it.
Or listen to him on a podcast,
the rich outdoors podcasts,
a hunting podcast.
Who is the strength coach you've talked to?
Do you think that you've gotten the most from
because you've talked to a lot of them.
You know,
I'm,
I've got,
I got a lot from Steve Maxwell for sure.
Um,
I've got a lot from listening to Pablo Tatsu Lean,
uh,
talk on other podcasts and talk on audio books.
And I've read his books too.
I feel like him,
he's a,
he's a big one.
Um,
uh,
Keith Webber,
we've had Keith Weber on the show.
He's the guy that has an extreme kettlebell cardio workout.
Uh,
the DVDs.
He's got three of them.
They're fucking insane.
They're so hard to do.
He doing with one 45 pound kettle bell and they'll kick your ass at the end of
the,
uh,
like 45 minutes,
I think 40,
40,
44 minutes.
Do you think,
do you train less?
Do you,
are you,
uh,
Eddie put your headphones on so you realize how loud opening that bag back and
forth is.
Are you somebody now who believes in training less than you did from talking to
those guys?
As in our most people ever trained,
this is what I think the,
what Pablo has going on is something that he calls greasing the groove.
And what he believes is you should never go to failure.
He's like,
your body is not designed to go to failure.
If you're doing,
uh,
like let's say if you're,
you're doing something that you could do 10 reps with it and then at 10,
you're like,
you should do five mm and they should walk away for five to 10 minutes.
Really do another five.
Yeah,
because if you're trying to get strong when you're trying to get strong,
the way you do it is continue to do those motions correctly with full strength.
And full,
you know,
full balance and full control of the kettle bell,
full control of the dumb bell,
whatever.
We,
you know,
if you're doing clean and press where they doing dead lifts with full control so
that you're,
you're lifting with perfect technique,
right.
And then take a long time off so that when you come back 10 minutes later your
body is on 100% recovered.
So you're not like still dying from the last set that you did 30 seconds ago.
Come on,
push it,
push it.
Push it
though.
Right.
That's just what we're talking about.
Strengths.
We're not talking about cardio.
If she wanted to do cardio,
your muscle building.
Well cause he's gonna bill you for sure.
Going to build a lot of muscle if you get stronger.
But there's a big difference between that and the hypertrophy if you are,
if you're trying to just gain weight,
he would trying to just get your muscles bigger and do like bodybuilding
exercises.
A lot of those dudes like to do pyramids.
They'll stack up the weight real high and then they dropped the weight down and
continue the reps until they have like almost no way,
you know.
But you know there's real questions as to whether or not that's a smart way to
train as an athlete.
And the,
the idea being is that as an athlete,
say if you have a brutal strength and conditioning workout where you're doing
everything to fail your dead lifts to failure,
a clean press to failure,
curls to failure,
but you know,
overhead press to failure the next day you're useless,
man,
you're useless.
You're not going to be able to spar,
you're not going to be able to,
dude,
you just,
you're going to get mauled.
But there's different phases for that.
I feel like there could be,
that's one way of looking at it.
But his way of looking at it is you do these workouts where you lift a small
percentage,
like half of what your,
what your actual Max would be in terms of repetitions and just take 10 minutes
off and then do that again.
10 10 minutes off.
Yup.
And take a long time off.
And do that again.
And by that way you leave and you still have a lot left in the tank.
You walk it,
these guys are fucking going at it.
Got down.
Yup.
Edson Barboza,
Benito diary,
which are throwing down days just coming straight food.
What was his car?
What about maxing out though?
What did they talk about with that?
You don't believe you should do it.
I mean you might want to do it every now and then just to find out where you
stand,
but it's not something that you should do on a regular basis for a workout.
Because I feel like a lot of sports are where you're maxing out your trying your
hardest if you're,
if you're fighting for sure if you're,
you know.
So it seems kind of intuitive,
like safe.
Why does it seem counterintuitive?
If you're doing strength,
if you're wrestling or you're doing Jiu Jitsu or you know,
a lot of times if you watch these guys,
they're spending a long time doing,
using their entire body and sort of probably in a maximum effort position,
right?
So,
so if you're trying to get out of a body lock or you're okay,
you know what I mean?
Or you in the class you stuff failure.
When do you ever go to failure in a sport?
Um,
well I don't,
I guess you don't,
you don't really go to muscle failure in a sport.
Where you do is you want to make sure those,
those muscles are strong and then you went to build up your technique.
Oh,
hi.
Kicked
by.
Barboza.
Wow.
Do you want to build up your technique and your endurance in the sport itself?
Like your ability to do rounds as a fighter,
right?
Grounds rolling in Jujitsu or what else?
Whatever else.
Other sport you're doing,
your real endurance training is probably going to come from sprints.
You're real endurance training is going to come from something different outside
of strength training that you're doing.
The sport itself is doing a sport itself or then again,
there's also argument for plyometrics,
which is a a great thing to do,
which is also sort of the same kind of result that you're getting from movement
training from a lot of other things that people,
what's plyometrics,
explosives,
jump box jumps,
jumping over hurdles.
If I said you can only do five exercises,
what would I say?
I'd say,
why?
Because let's just say,
can I do five one of the five months when you writing a strength condition book,
I would say you should do more than five things because people don't have that
much time.
It's fucking people need to go fuck themselves.
Squats,
push ups,
pull ups,
don't ask any stupid questions.
Back squats,
dead lifts.
I'd say squats,
dead lifts,
Chin ups are huge and I think weighted chin ups or even more huge.
I'm a big believer in way to chin ups.
I love putting a one of those,
a dip belts on with a kettle bell in between my legs and doing chin ups that way
because it makes my,
my Max Chin ups go way higher and I do them with strict form none of that.
That airy fairy United to kick cross fell into Kipp.
Him being not kipper.
No,
I'm not kidding.
I had you pegged as a kept my brother.
You know what I think?
I think she'd be able to do strict form pull ups and find out how much endurance
you actually have in your arms without moving your legs with it and everything
else strict in the strong first and paddles a organization you have to be able
to do straight pull ups like,
like from the bottom,
full extension damp annealed Irish with a big kick to the body is bullying him.
He's going straight forward and let him tee off.
This is a crazy ass fight.
Nice knee to the body.
I feel it.
Diarrhea sambal guy or a a a Greco guy.
So richly to black belt in Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is nasty and he's a hot field corp students.
Amazing.
Ooh,
kick to the body by Barboza Barboza so fucking fast.
[inaudible] man.
Which when the standup game,
I don't know about all that.
It's close by.
Bose has been fighting a long time,
I feel like.
Oh,
lefthand by dairy.
Who's nice.
The thing about Barboza is he can just always turn out the lights with one shot.
He's explosive.
He's,
and he also does a lot of wild shit like head kicks and things that can take you
out there.
She's the underdog.
I liked him as an underdog.
If I was betting on it,
it felt still fighting.
I haven't seen him.
Yeah.
Wow.
Just one killer.
You know he majored in theater school inside leg kick.
Who did?
Felder just fought.
Just fought.
Where did I learn to speak English?
I was case that with that he took a little time on our boss,
but he did when his last fight did he not?
I believe he did.
Is it fun?
A little bit.
The Smart Guy Man.
Really smart guy
up 19th and beat Alisandra Ricci.
There we go.
Thank you.
He's tough as shit.
He took off so bought in flinch month ago.
Jesus.
Oh,
those kids are so hellish.
Aw
Yeah.
Barbara is,
it might be the best kicker in this fucking division.
Wow.
You really saw that in the PR in the Pettis fight.
Can you think of another bet who would be a better kicker?
No Damn Damn.
But you know guys,
take it.
Look at this pod.
Jamie Varner fight.
Holy Shit.
Like wonder boy.
He is a phenomenal kick it different though.
As far as like leg kicks,
body cakes.
Barboza is number one for me.
No,
it's pretty goddamn good while eating over here.
I'm trying to think of the really good kickers,
but as far as that,
yeah,
I,
I'll see cowboys amazing with this setups.
I just feel like Barboza and then yeah,
your Rodriguez on another universe do.
How about him and
huge jump.
That's such a big leap for a Dominick Cruz.
His point about how Frankie Edgar is,
you see a lot of fighters at once they start losing,
they never recover.
And then you see certain fighters like Frankie Edgar who even though they look
like they're down and out,
always find a way to come back in the fight.
Yeah,
yeah.
There certain fighters,
you know,
once they,
somebody else gets the advantage they,
you know,
they tend to not be able to kind of come back from it.
And guys like frank cake or coffee all over myself.
That's great.
This a coffee thing,
something happens with it when you press it.
Oh is that two full rang out?
A lot of pressure built up Joe.
Yeah,
but why is it so I need to,
it's physics.
I need a pointer in a fucking carbon black board.
Oh,
you wouldn't be faking.
I could show you dude.
You don't know.
You don't know how much physics I had to at least guys are banging man.
Yeah.
I like,
how dare you.
She's being aggressive going,
God.
Oh my God.
What the fuck is he wearing?
An invisible helmet.
Oh,
Brian,
you should write for some sort of a badge sitcoms.
Thanks buddy.
Is that a compliment?
I hope so.
I can never figure it out.
What is he wearing?
Some sort of a helmet.
Helmet.
If that was in a movie,
I'd be like,
what kind of Douche bag?
I wasn't doing a movie in the way then the movie warrior guys get it.
Please.
I might see a penny.
It was amazing when you brought out the fish bowl.
I don't want to talk about it.
Right.
I was like,
if you ever,
ever in a script,
I've never seen it.
If someone brought that up in a scrub and I'd be like,
Hey,
see this part?
No,
absolutely not.
No.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the part I get the most compliments on.
Oh,
world.
Cause who are you hanging out with?
Let's not talk to you.
I don't want to talk about
other actors,
Bro.
Hey,
uh,
other just nine
Barboza was five.
I got to come on.
I got to come out in the hallway.
I'm at night busy.
Never matched it up.
Oof.
Okay.
Damn dirty.
She's put that down to a single aw,
great takedown defense by Barboza Swanson above.
That is a weird fight,
man.
Such a random fight.
I mean Swanson's like what is your rank number five or something like that.
Yeah,
and low balled wasn't even top 20 no,
it's so,
it was like talking shit to him then maybe pulled the Connor flag,
you know?
It's like,
Hey,
counters my boy.
Like I do it.
That's a weird fight though.
It's a weird random as fuck.
If you're a cub,
what's it do for you?
I guess,
you know,
it keeps him busy,
makes them look,
you're a superstar.
If he wins,
maybe lose.
Do you get in better shape,
but even him,
you know what I mean?
That's the thing about Barboza.
As good as his fucking technique is,
as good as his kickboxing is,
he still gets tagged.
Everybody gets tagged.
This is a brutal goddamn sport.
Yep.
Fucking canvas.
Yeah.
I mean,
as good as he is,
as good as Barboza is the messiest canvas I've seen a lot.
Usually they clean that shit up for farms.
They spray it won a Tony for fights right there.
This is Fox.
Oh this is fs one fs one is not nearly the reach that big Fox as if that was big
Fox.
They wouldn't have to torture us man.
It's one of the reasons why I hated doing big Fox is cause they would get out
there with spray paint and they would spray paint the fucking color on the
octagon all over that gray area and non toxic.
I'm sure.
Oh it's brutal it but blow right over to your face.
You knew you were breathing in some horrible shit.
She's using real spray paint.
Yes.
It's totally illegal.
I guarantee you it's some shit that they would do if they were like working on a
car somewhere.
You know it's terrible primer.
I don't know who authorized it.
I don't know why they were allowed to do it.
But we would be sitting there cage side and toxic fucking fumes from spray paint
or being blasted all over that canvas calling it the flood.
Yes.
They see want to see the blood cause they didn't want him to let go.
My God.
People on Big Fox.
They didn't want to admit what they're setting up.
God Damn it.
A bloody sport.
So you'd be sitting there doing commentary and you'd be coughing.
You'd have to like pull your shirt up above your face like this.
Like fucking Amen.
And the guys who are doing the sound,
we're like,
this is fucking brutal.
I can't believe they're doing this sucks that these guys are just coming out
this fucking Daria.
She's like,
go.
Hey God damn,
he's good damn diary.
She looks real smooth on his feet.
The thing about Barboza though,
you've got to always wonder,
you got to always wonder when he's going to uncork something on you.
He's got such good footwork too,
ma'am.
Yeah he does.
That's that Mark Henry Man.
Cause he wasn't always like this
damn
well he used to be a little more
dag.
My
God.
Oh my God.
Like you just said,
he's like you just said
you shut up and said,
Oh shit that Mario Yamasaki the raft.
Do you see him come fucking bulldog.
Amen.
Zacky ahead.
Cause he didn't want to get timing on that knee.
That's Mark Henry.
Powerful market.
Are you kidding?
Good.
Lower.
Yup.
Nice.
Oh,
I can't wait to see this replay with the fucking knee was insane.
He's all right.
I want to know what the Fuck Mario runs in the 40 [inaudible].
How fast that was with TC.
I've never seen a react that way,
man.
I'm man ticketless.
Here it is.
What was the left knee jumping knee?
I don't even remember it.
Look at this.
Jan there
looked like he was going to look
and cluck off as good for that RAF.
That's great job on that.
That blog fucking that wasn't Yamazaki it was,
I can't tell Mario he's got amazing.
No,
no,
that's not my
best friends I haven't seen.
Yeah.
Well we'll see.
There are free when we see them
relax now.
He was good.
He was good though.
He wanted to save Darya.
That's a good breakfast.
So it wasn't Mario Yamasaki who is a referee?
I don't know that Maya.
Oh yeah.
Good job.
Awesome job dude.
Powerful bull.
I don't know,
but the both of them.
Brazil's there.
A lot of mines in Brazil.
Probably his brother cause he really rich Franklin's brother used to do,
we used to referee and you look at me like,
hey man,
wait
no you fry man.
Rich Frank.
Let's think about him the other day I was watching a replay at him verse
Anderson and Cincinnati.
He was such a fun fighter.
Maybe as a math teacher look like ace Ventura.
Yeah,
that's his whole spiel.
You're a big tough motherfucker and one of the first guys to come in and insane,
insane,
surreal,
weird workout though.
I think today it would be,
it would be kind of frowned upon a lot of the exercises he was doing cause he
was doing a lot of like isolation exercises and really super high repetitions.
You know,
you remember he was doing like machines,
like the isolation machine.
That's shit worked though for him.
For him.
It worked until aunt Sylvia came along.
Yeah.
Well cool story bro.
Check get these knees.
Yeah,
you're doing what?
Let me go get this plum real quick and knee or knows.
How about that.
Look at this.
Look at this card Weidman versus Musashi.
April 8th did you see the poster?
DC was so pissed.
I know because what the fucking shit.
Why?
Because rumbles like 80 times.
Very then I'm rumble.
Looks like King Kong sitting over and he's the little poor white girl.
It's very strange
guys con looming in the background.
Yeah man.
Like,
like he beat him before some shit.
Like you didn't get choked the fuck out in the front.
No.
Right?
I don't know.
They look the same size.
No,
no,
that's not it.
That's not it.
DC.
Literally it was like,
what the fuck is this?
A poster the DC put on Instagram.
Jamie,
see if you could find this.
Call them out.
Like who made this?
I'm the champ for sakes.
Barboza with insane knee.
Holy Shit.
That was good.
That ref.
We need to check him for fucking so one more time.
Let's say it here.
I see some motion.
The fucking job,
man.
Come on.
Perfect.
Ah,
we're back up.
He just went,
oh,
okay.
Here you go.
Do a little,
for sure.
That's his brother.
It looks like to me and they looked very similar.
It looks super similar.
Google it.
You might be racist as fuck though.
There might be a shitload them know.
It's weird like you can say it's racist,
but that dude is white as fuck.
Yea.
It's like there it is.
Look at the dots.
[inaudible] Johnson poster.
Like you can't see it.
Shit.
Well that's crazy.
Ridiculous.
Weird.
Yeah.
That's red and shit.
Whoever did that should get fired.
The Post is ridiculous cause you know off the Johnson's are knocked out artists
and he's winning.
But DC your Chapman and he beat him before Johnson's looming over him.
I guess they fought before.
What is this?
Is this the same reason why that Ronda Rousey video was all Rhonda and very
little about Amanda Nunez?
It's difficult.
Neither one of them's a draw.
So does it.
Oh,
you don't think people want to see rumble fight?
I do.
But if,
if like just a rumble fights on a big draw.
I mean you do.
I love Vermont.
Listen,
I'm not complaining about robot and rumble.
Fight for the title is different than anybody else fighting for the title
rumble.
Johnson numbers would be on my side on this argument.
Joe,
not an argument.
I'm just saying like he doesn't pull in huge numbers paper.
I think you're probably right,
but I think he has the potential to be a massive star and that's what they're
seeing with is not the way.
Yeah.
The way he puts guys to sleep.
Johnson,
I think rumble Johnson.
John Jones House more than rumble Johnson.
Daniel Cormay.
Well they fought and beat them.
Yeah,
I think you're right.
What could his timing on his fucking knee,
but dude,
Uhm,
oh my God.
I mean that's about as perfect and knee is anybody's ever thrown in life.
That's a perfect timing.
He wasn't winning that fight before that crazy lot of my card.
Oh,
well I didn't have a card.
Do you have a card?
Yeah,
I'm right here.
Here we go.
And that ref MVP.
Damn Edson Barboza was a beast.
Number five.
Just be Dariusz knocked him out.
He was a fun one coming up.
What a crazy division.
That one 55 is boiling murder,
Bro.
That shit together.
Oh yeah.
You have to be able to do everything because even this guy gets out of work by
people.
Yeah,
man.
He's lost some big hello pedis pedis now has to come back to this shit and joy.
That is,
yeah,
but 55 for him,
but he didn't really have that bad of a run at 55 plus couple decisions.
Oh listen,
when he was on top of 55 when he knocked out cowboy Cerrone with that body kick
knocked out,
Joe Lozan tapped out and Benson Henderson to win the title.
He can still do work.
He's still,
he's a beast.
He's a beast of an athlete and he's still fairly young.
I feel like with a guy like that,
like the,
it's almost like he has to take some time and get his body to the perfect weight
and strength to compete at one 55 thing.
Joe,
where's he at?
Mentally like he's been to the top of Everest.
He stayed.
He's put the flag in there.
You know what it takes to get there.
Do you still want to do that?
Like you've been through all this,
do you really want to restart from the bottom and go up and you can tell what
it's like up there?
Is it any different?
Yeah.
And you're dealing with all the issues,
physical issues.
This DC rumble fucking promo.
Tom,
um,
something that's going to be a fun fight.
I like Weidman Musashi on that too.
Yeah,
that's a very fun,
fine.
I liked that.
Find a lot.
The Dallas card is,
everybody's on it.
Katrina's real good on that one.
Yeah.
I don't even know where to start.
I mean,
can you bring that up?
We'll just look at it.
There's so many Eddie.
My mind's gone.
Well,
it's a heavyweight title,
right?
It's junior dos Santos versus Steve.
John,
uh,
John Jay.
Check on that bitch and now she's fighting here.
Go,
go high on that.
She's fighting Jessica.
Raj.
Um,
yeah man.
Oh,
Eddie Alvarez pour.
Yay.
Yeah.
Oh,
what does this
Marzola ain't doing shit when he moved in.
He tez and Riki.
Barsol that's interesting that that's on the main card.
I don't think that that does that.
It's not set yet.
They're just toss them up there.
Cause the Frankie Edgar,
now you're Rodriguez is a burn.
Oh my goodness.
I think it's too much right here.
But getting insurance for for a year this soon does he just murdered and then
Henry.
So Hudl versus Sergio Pettis.
Holy Shit.
I know.
Damn Sergio Pettis got some serious abs back up real quick.
But what in the fuck so called the golden snitch.
Jesus Christ.
He's not passing the sniff test.
The golden snitch us.
You Ain't pass inside of your shredded.
Wow.
What a fucking card.
Look at that car.
Pettis has quietly becoming,
you know,
a real bad ass and the division,
the real fight in the car that I'm interested in the most honestly is Frankie
Edgar versus Yahya Rodriguez.
I'm looking forward to that as much as Damien Maia math.
But the hall is much thinner.
That's going sizzler.
Yeah,
but dude,
Yani Rodriguez is doing some crazy street fighter shit in there.
I want to sin.
I want to see what he could do to Frankie if he can land a three 60 roundhouse
kick on Frankie Edgar.
We've got a party.
I don't like that fight son.
The parties with a steep a dos Santos.
That's the party too,
right?
Did that.
And it was a close fight.
Mad,
sad face May 13th it's a while.
Yeah.
When you get punched to changes.
When?
When Cain Velasquez fucking 10 rises your faith for tenants,
he looks more and more evil.
He looks like he's the guy,
couldn't be the nice and couldn't get any nicer night day.
That'd be the most friendliest guy in the world.
Steve is a good dude too,
but that's a great fucking fight
they're to do.
They're trying to do Eddie Alvarez versus Ferguson first one like,
Nah man,
I'm waiting for this title shot on Eddie to look at Shogun.
The network looks kind of strange.
No,
it looks real slow doing it for the cameras fellas.
They're warming up,
you know.
But they come in,
they might already warmed up and they,
when they come in they go,
hey,
we're going to get you now on film and just,
you're almost called,
you stand up and you're not,
this isn't real.
That guy to the ride has been
plus you don't want to show it too much.
That's a crazy fight though.
Shogun has been in so many wars.
Oh,
you always like,
how many more warrants can that guy be in?
Wait,
what's this
kicking ass again,
dude,
she's babied us constantly kicking ass.
She's super body though.
Yup.
She got them robot tits.
Hey guys,
seriously.
It's bad.
Don't be misogynist.
It's women's mom.
I have to check.
What is the misogyny?
Does that mean like you hate women?
She say she has a nice,
it does not mean your massage.
No,
she went,
Oh man,
you have some nice,
but if you say she,
yeah.
If she,
you say she's got some nice to ties.
That's being real.
Is that kind of problem with the way the flashiness,
the way the left brands,
any kind of like the narrative of feminism,
like a femme women are victims.
Men are oppressors and toxic and predators and you can't have a discussion from
that.
It's like just cause I think a woman's beautiful and I compliment her or she
turns me on.
It doesn't mean I want to oppress her.
It just means they want to have sex with her.
I feel like we turned the corner on that.
I feel like we're turning the corner on the team yet.
We haven't.
Yeah.
But I think that they're being critiqued on a,
on a level that they've never really been critiqued it.
Good,
good.
I'm glad to hear that.
Don't mean,
don't you think,
I mean with the kind of scrutiny that they receive online?
I do.
The problem is I think most of us are living in our own echo chambers.
I think the biggest problem with online online stuff is that most of us are able
to create our own echo chambers.
And so there isn't enough,
uh,
exchange of ideas and I think we all need to kind of open up and I think you
should listen to the people you disagree with as much as you possibly can to see
what you don't like about them and what they're really saying.
If you rely on just the media,
what they're gonna do is they're going to,
they're going to highlight four sentences that you said over and over.
And what the biggest problem we have is that you can say one sentence and people
brand this very complex human being who is always changing day to day and
they'll brand you with the label.
You're a sexist,
you're a racist,
you're Amazon.
Well,
human beings are very different.
I'm,
I'm very different day to day.
Some depending on my mood,
I say some fucked up shit.
Then I say some really nice things and depending on how I feel,
but I know who I am defining people through a few tweets or a blog or article or
something like that.
You're talking about a human's entire life.
It's ridiculous.
It doesn't move ideas forward.
What's also the reality of censorship?
I mean you're,
you're attempting to instead of debate people and their ideas and offer superior
ideas yeah.
And put your ideas to the test instead of doing that,
they want to silence speech.
So they want us,
they want to stop people like Jordan Peterson.
There's,
uh,
a university just called them transphobic and to try to get him kicked off of a
thing and go get it was I think they are,
I think it was in,
I want to say it was in Dublin.
Charles Murray will speak at the university.
Well a lot of people have not been allowed to speak recently.
And in these leftists universities,
they won't even let you speak because you have a different idea because you
might have an idea that grates against the common orthodoxy.
And Jordan Peterson by the way,
is anything but transphobic.
He's absolutely not.
And the only thing that he said is he doesn't want to use a bunch of made up
gender stereotypes or gender pronouns,
brother.
Or how about the fact that I have to give you verbal consent and bets.
You're getting into my bedroom telling me how to speak.
It did,
this is,
um,
I don't think we've seen anything like this and that's the problem.
And you,
it has to be fought against it just because it's a form of tyranny.
And by the way,
again,
the,
the reason a lot of the liberal press has lost their credibility is because they
harp on they'll brand like think about even with Trump,
well I'm not a fan,
a fan of,
they brand him all of these things where it's kind of the how,
what are we supposed to do with that kind of when you,
when you call somebody that is it over now or we just done with that person or
is there a,
is there a smarter way to break somebody down?
Yeah.
I don't know man.
It's,
it's especially at the left.
I love how the left tries to,
you know,
speaking of like if you,
if you dislike Trump,
the way I would fight Trump is I would do this.
I would go,
he's not a Democrat,
he's not a Republican.
He's not even an American.
He's a Trumpist.
He's a monarch.
That's how you get the second amendment guys on your side.
If you're a liberal and you want to get the other people on your side,
it doesn't work that way.
You can a second amendment guys,
if he supports them,
frame the left doesn't,
the left doesn't support second amendment rights.
So if he does,
he gets them.
It's really that simple.
Or you frame the debate a different way.
Right?
So so your be more fair about,
be more specific and detailed on how you criticize somebody.
Forget Trump.
Anybody know what you don't like about that person?
Because there's a lot to like about a lot of people,
even if they're assholes.
I think,
I mean the people are complicated,
right?
We all have friends and they,
all of us have friends that we love and they have aspects of their personality.
We don't necessarily like day to day,
right?
Some nights they're idiots in certain ways,
but we forgive him because we know that in talking about yourself now I'm
talking about taking me out,
talking to people who feel like he's given us.
We need a moment of silence which showed that a locked up.
It might be the last time we see him,
right?
Yeah,
man,
you never know.
I mean how many more years can that guy go out?
Mount Rushmore and he's a bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
About 40 guys on my mouth.
Yeah,
you must mount Rushmore has to be big as fuck.
Cause don't give me four or five.
Well first of all,
you have to have hoists.
Gracie Gracie's on Mount Rushmore period.
Right.
He was the original guy that set it all off whether or not let me still get
bullied numbers with that.
Ken shamrock.
Crazy,
crazy numbers.
Huge numbers.
Millions plus.
He's got to be on it.
But that's kind of like the way babe Ruth would be on Mount Rushmore for cause
he's one of the first.
So yes.
Makes it even started at pioneers.
Yeah.
But Babe Ruth and hoists Gracie that they did work,
they just didn't start it like they did fucking work.
Right?
Like Babe Ruth's numbers are legitimate.
She always,
Gracie did something spectacular.
You introduced the idea that a smaller man could be a bigger man in a real life
fight and with techniques that you've never seen before.
[inaudible] 16 man tournament.
Yeah.
Yes.
You never see,
nobody saw triangles before.
Hoists.
Gracie tapped out.
Dan Severen.
No one even knew what the fuck he was doing and then when when you try to bring
it back to go like in 1993 try going to your local Jujitsu school,
tell him to teach you that.
Oh,
that's advanced.
They were not teaching people triangles because they thought that shit was
advanced.
I know a dude,
I know it it to went through a certain Jujitsu school right afterwards and they
told him,
we can't teach you triangles yet.
You're not ready for that yet.
That's advanced techniques.
They were holding shit back from people fade or is on that Mount Rushmore for
sure.
100% faders on there and then current guys,
I'd say cane.
How many guys can you have on rush?
My artist too many.
There's two.
Mount Rushmore is,
it's got to be another thing for,
you can't have four fours and salvage GSP.
We know that.
Right.
How did they decide who was going to itself and she has to pay 100% how did they
decide?
It's a good question.
Do you know what he,
I have no idea.
Who are the guys that have stayed at the top for a long time.
Anderson Silva,
GSP and finished dudes.
Well yeah,
but then what about Matt Hughes?
Hughes finished GSP in a title fight.
How long was it Matt who is on top of a while?
Quite a while.
Most women gay.
So that's another real pioneer that change the game and a lot of ways because he
introduced the idea that high level wrestling plus submissions,
like when he hit that far side arm bar on GSP,
GSP went for a Kimora and he didn't secure the legs.
And Matt,
he was spun around that far side arm bar and locked it in.
It was beautiful.
And then what about Uriah Faber?
What he did for the little guy and then Wa favor you've got,
but no,
but hold on.
You're right.
The problem with Uriah Faber as he never wanted UFC title,
and I think if you're talking about a UFC hall fame in his prime grade,
he wanted a WC.
How am I Bj Penn?
He did.
Bj Penn's gotta be in there,
he's got the care before.
It can't be full of 150 full.
I don't know how to choose after you got to choose stresses me that can't I get
stressed.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
I don't want to do it.
This guy,
is there a heavy weight in there?
What heavyweight to choose?
It'd be probably fade or Taylor or retainer and there's argument for for doom.
No,
not for,
not for dinner.
How dare you know?
Care might be up there,
but I don't care.
It might be up there.
I think federal right over dominance for a long period of time.
What about Dominick Cruz knocking dude out.
Amazing.
Yeah.
He only lost twice.
Once by choke and once by decision.
You know the last place chosen long ass time ago at one 45 John Jones.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you can't ever lost,
he came up with John's never lost.
I think you've going to dude's ass and got this call.
Anderson Silva.
Conor McGregor.
Yeah,
you do.
You don't like talking about pine,
like game changers.
You have to look at a couple of things.
Longevity,
like how long were they on top?
That's got to take a place.
Right.
Let's talk about criteria for it.
How long have you been on top?
Uh,
how did you,
did you finish dudes?
That's kind of how many finishes that,
that's got to play a factor.
What do you mean?
So how long you been in the top?
So how,
you know,
how long were you champ?
How long did you hold the belt?
That's,
that's got to play a factor.
Yeah,
that's a big fat.
How long,
how did you do it?
Did you finish?
How many people did you actually finish your competition too?
Sometimes guys get dominant and they're in a slump in the division.
Like when Mike Tyson came along and was Merck and everybody,
and there was,
you know Tony tubs?
Yeah.
He's like,
he's fighting Bruce Selden on my mount Rushmore for that reason.
He's on my mount Rushmore to GSP fought everybody and stayed on top forever.
Everybody Hoists Bj,
Jon Jones.
Anderson Silva,
GSP.
What about
what about mighty mouse and fade or not John?
John's.
Well,
see Jon Jones has never lost though and he's beating all those other guys.
It was the youngest champ.
How long was he up on top for two years.
No long though.
It's been on longer than that.
You know he beat,
he beat Shogun when he was 23 man,
so it's never lost weight.
He's 30 now.
You don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
Seven years.
B.
He wasn't on top of seven years.
Oh wait a minute.
He's on top of,
I'm sorry.
Excuse me.
How about Josie Aldo?
He's ahead of John Jones.
His knee.
Yeah,
but he got knocked out by Conor Mcgregor.
He lost after nine years.
Yeah,
but there's a reality.
You've got to look at someone based on the overall,
the overall performance of their career.
He held the belt.
No,
you lost phenomenal.
The big fight,
the big fight that he had against his biggest fan of that,
Jon Jones.
Huge.
You have to count all that.
He doesn't matter.
He's went through Hawaii,
so he went through,
I'm like a hot knife through butter.
That was the old,
that was fine.
Dad bought,
this is what it is.
People fade or Coleman.
That's the Mark Coleman.
He changed a lot of shit to UFC.
He's the one who brought wrestlers the problem.
I know one of you have a seatbelt and a pride by knows route.
We're stand Henderson on that bitch.
That's a good question.
Engevity but time division champion itch simultaneously.
Never Strike Force to championship.
Fuck everyone.
Amazing.
Awesome.
You could argue that he might've won that decision against Bisping.
He was anywhere other than England.
A lot of people have argued that.
I understand,
but I'm talking about people that held the belt.
You got,
you have to use bell holders for love with Dan was fighting in pride,
but Dan was fighting for the belt against business.
Stan,
if he beats Bisbing and wins the middleweight title,
you've got to look at him as like con top five of all time.
He's still taught,
but there's still as far as far as this trial,
not top five,
but who knows what the number is.
There's too many.
Oh,
these guys are throwing hard right away.
Put
it right in front of this kid.
The three most dominant winters.
Tough dude too,
man.
It needs a big fucking guy.
Football player or a football player.
Big Tool five or man,
big strong motherfucker.
This is,
he played football.
He played just college.
College,
Hofstra.
Oh Jesus.
God.
She'll get until he's had a granite chin.
Oh Shit.
Them son tagged him.
Power.
Goodness by Shogun.
This is a crazy fly holding,
which is the body
that's that veteran approach for sure.
Power one.
How old is ruined now?
Shoguns got some weird thing going on this right all and that isn't it right
peck,
he sprout 30 32 at the moment.
I think he's 30 yeah.
Shogun shogun 35 that's old.
And I thought,
and I thought he was 32 those are powerful soon cause he was the shortest shorts
by far.
Anyone this actually,
do you see how his right pack?
He's got some weird thing going on.
Like where it's,
it was pet connects over by shoulder.
It's almost like something's torn there.
Oh he looks soft
closing it.
Oh Jesus Christ.
It looks,
he looks fun.
Not Tell you it using the soft cap very nicely.
He's,
he's never had a good body.
I now I know,
but it just a little softer in the mail for 35 he looks pretty fucking good,
right?
It doesn't look like it's a young,
he doesn't look bad,
but this is a crazy way to fight.
It's a crazy way to fight shogun though in that I know,
but in Brazil still fucked.
We expect stand.
Hey,
over the top of the right hand.
Oh my God.
Fuck.
Playing Shogun in Brazil and he's also like to fight win streak three fight.
I mean he's ranked number six,
man.
He's not like just some washed up that [inaudible] is doing a good job at
keeping that left hand up high in avoiding that big overhand cause.
He keeps him over the child though.
You can count it over the top,
but [inaudible] has been doing a good job with see that blocking that
one goes through,
right?
That's getting,
he's getting cat that Jab.
Come on over that Jab.
They've abandoned kicks,
abandoned kicks,
abandoned kicks.
Everyone's just wrestling.
Just fuck it.
Let's just box each eaches face.
That's when he tell dudes had been dinged up and they get dinged up a little
bit.
Oh there you go.
Shogun throughs through like sort of a halfhearted inside leg kick and you know
bill hunt,
they can fucking wrestle.
He takes students down.
He trains with Weidman
but
couldn't take a big deep breath at two minutes ago.
This is the way the high pace for two oh five yeah.
Oh Shit.
His Jab is starting to bust shogun ups.
He is eye that right eye and the nose is that jab man.
You just shogun still fuck with that unit brow still.
It still rolls with it.
You know Jimmy,
he's like Anthony Davis says it's my thing.
Oh Harry,
you don't want wax.
Oh cause not to train with a wide main guy.
He also trains with WHO's out of the God,
the kickboxing Delmore kickboxing guy.
Oh over the top of the right hand.
Oh
God.
Damn.
Both of them got granted.
A GSPS kickbox and trainer.
Which one?
Oh you're thinking of a field nurse.
Yeah.
Does he still nurses,
trans guys.
Trans Guy.
Cause he was John's guy for a little bit.
And he was George Guy.
I don't see him in the background anymore.
I met with some guys.
Oh Jesus Christ.
You're the most beautiful gym I've ever seen.
The Watt in New York City.
Yes.
God.
Damn.
It must cost like $500 a month at least.
How much does it cost to work out there for you?
If you had to guess?
Everything is so expensive in New York City.
$100,000 a month.
It had guys.
Good guess.
Good guess to find out.
Jamie,
what monthly rates are at the Watt in New York City?
It's w.
A.
T.
It's all wood flooring and shit,
like what is going on and then the ring.
Oh Shit.
All Wood flooring.
Is it like real stylish in there?
It's beautiful,
man.
He was a great kickboxer man.
Phil nurses,
a bad motherfucker and great coach too.
Yeah,
he's better at money.
It's so expensive for rent there.
I mean,
what is,
what is rent in New York City?
It's insane.
Especially where he's at.
Did you'd have talked to people that have like a,
a tiny ass little apartment and you talk to them.
You're like,
how much do you pay a month?
$4,000 for a studio.
So that means you have to make $50,000 a year just to pay for this apartment.
Yeah,
that's insane.
Hundred Square feet.
So if you make a hundred grand a year,
half of it is going to your studio apartment.
Biggest problem is so much,
so much Chinese and Russian and foreign money moved into New York and started
buying problems.
And so when they sit,
they sit empty because it's a safe place to put your money.
So they built these towers where you people are buying literally spending three
grand a square foot for apartments that are sitting there empty and they rent
them out.
Well,
it's a place based solutions,
a fairly rich to keep their money.
I get it,
but we're going to be safe.
Can you say that Brennan Shop,
but in 10 years when you're
Paul and out of control and you decide to buy some penthouse house up there and
just keep it be,
it's just for this,
for some sort of an investment.
You're right.
You're right,
Jill.
Yeah,
man.
You would have some dope ass.
I can have hosts.
That was one of the best things about that.
A Dr strange movie.
The doctor strange movie.
Oh shitty Cleveland with that.
Right?
The doctor,
strange movie doctor strange before he becomes the mystic spoiler alert.
He lives in Manhattan and he has this fucking insane view and that's like a real
thing.
Like you really can get a view like that and some of those apartments are
scrooge McDuck and if he,
but if you can afford that view at nighttime,
God damn it is one of the most spectacular things that you could see out your
windows in a place where you,
I think that I think like being in Manhattan that and then only like a dope ass
crib in Malibu facing the beach doesn't give a shit.
Oh those two things together.
Yes.
The problem is like what are you doing there though?
What are you doing in New York City?
Just going to restaurants and having parties come stand girl.
I might just stay home and look out the window.
I might be like,
well look,
if you want the one get,
you got to want to get rich.
Right?
So why do you want to get rich?
While I want to be able to do whatever I want and I want to be able to go nice
places.
I want to be able to eat nice food and,
and see nice things.
Okay,
well let's add up all those experiences and how cool are they in comparison to
looking out your window?
Yeah,
and I would have fucking spectacular 30 story view.
Think if you had this studio up then,
now they're little background.
Now you're with your boys.
Well I was thinking about renting a place downtown.
No,
just,
oh,
sorry.
Sorry.
Let's get in the way.
Isn't that what people,
when you think about the guy who was born with lots of money and he's got that
crazy crab,
what you really think?
Let's be honest.
Opposite thing.
Oh,
it's amazing.
Good food.
Champagne slots for days.
I mean that's what most behind like that guy's got to be banging like,
you know,
I dunno how,
I'm sorry.
Wow.
That shit during women's nice guy.
Sorry.
Women's month or do they go,
uh,
let's see what other people think,
Dan Bilzerian so he's going to want you to think that guys say,
hey,
that's someone's job or bending over for Sushi right now.
Could be that shit.
Come on,
look at that.
It's been over in a g g string.
He's out of control.
No,
he's totally in control.
I mean,
it's just,
that's,
that's what I mean.
That's what everybody,
that's a way,
that's where you spend your money,
dude.
Hashtag International Women's Day,
Pete,
painful.
What's wrong with that dude?
Seven fun.
Yeah.
He's held
no regrets there.
John Volante starting to pour it on here.
He's stepping in with that jab and Shogun keeps throwing that looping overhand.
Right?
It's finding a lame a little bit.
Sometimes it,
sometimes he clipped him on the temple and dropped them.
There's your months,
you know,
that's the same overhand,
right that he knocked out.
I'm not.
I'm Liotta with Wimber.
He caught it.
It was at the top.
Ooh.
He tagged him with that right hand.
Really aren't.
They looked a little,
well,
I think they've been paying it so he should be a little fatigue.
They're both a little fatigued.
Do not quit though,
and just fucking off.
It looks bigger.
It looks way bigger.
He's a big boy.
He's been doing really well with that Jab.
But look at that counter of that right hand over the top right there.
That was clean.
And then Sjogren's patient on in too.
When he puts it together,
he was just all in one shot there.
Now when he puts two together,
they'd lay in two to three land forum.
I'm shocked at how much these guys have abandoned their cakes.
Shocked.
Zubin one.
Yeah,
there's been a few early.
They're kind of exchanging blows too,
aren't they?
Just
slobber knocker right?
Yeah,
but I mean Jesus shoguns wobbled a little,
cracked him,
but it's just like these guys are,
they're heavy on their legs.
If somebody's uncorked,
a solid leg kick there.
Isn't that Sjogren's thing?
Canty oh yeah.
Well he can kick the fuck out of here.
I could volunteer with the take down.
Not Up.
We assumed as don't bring that shit into my cage.
Don't ever bring that shit into my cage,
Brian,
that you are back in the movie again.
I'm just saying.
That's what I say.
It's what I fucking say.
Feel it.
Feel it right now.
Don't bring that shit into my cage.
Oh,
that's how you wobbled him with that dude.
Oh Jesus.
Oh Shit.
We slept.
Oh boy.
Yeah,
but he's in trouble.
He's in trouble.
A little and wobbly.
Oh,
he got right back up.
Wow.
Take some space.
He's just tired.
He's tough.
Ish as this top.
That's fine.
This is only the second round kids.
This pace is nuts,
man.
Especially the blows.
Oh,
she always in that shogun spreading in this field.
Opening it for the shoe box.
Old School Combo.
Shut the box.
She,
when you watch shogun fight,
you just want to go.
Just think of how many wars this guy's been in the gym.
They get how many wars this guy's been in the ring and then in the cage it's
still doing the day.
I'm still doing it and he just wants to pluck as utero stuff saying,
hey man,
I'm [inaudible] to my left.
As I respect the absolute warrior,
like that's how I would describe him.
Like he's just doing the damn thing.
Loves to fight again with that overhand right.
He's,
he keeps timing that well,
he's starting to find openings to,
I think a lot of that is also going to the body enough.
The more it's going to body.
Yeah.
A little baby.
One little head movement.
A little movement,
man.
I'm not mad at Shogun sweep that folks can leg looks really good.
I mean he's taking some shots but,
and philosophies,
no choke man.
Not at all,
man.
So he keeps calling the custody.
I like how he's going to the body and mix it up.
You guys ever read that book?
Shogun?
It's great.
I don't think it's the same thing.
Okay.
There his brother Ninja,
he retired from concussion.
He had some brain injuries.
He had to get like surgery.
Oh Jeez.
Oh,
we deemed them with that right.
Is for Rodley.
Ooo,
think about suddenly shogun looks bigger.
Female.
Billy Anthony's.
It's freaking Baca to,
he's middle linebacker at Hofstra.
So there has to be some sort of brain damage you'd think game.
Hmm.
More.
He's one of those dudes where it's no offense,
you know,
he's just one of those dudes to it.
Those dudes don't exist.
Remember that Samoan Guy was shot himself?
What was his name?
Yeah.
That guy is like,
no one's more durable than 15 years.
They like the most durable human beings on the planet and everybody gets it in
the long run.
More content.
I begged the for.
He's not really that laugh.
The last one I seen him go flatline like that.
Only in the Melvin Manhoef fight.
Remember Melvin column?
I
fought him.
He says he is.
Yes.
Smaller than him.
Hi.
Smaller Melvin was one 80 oh my God.
Your mom close to 60 oh my God.
And Melvin Kao them with One Punch Card and k one or one straight powers was the
key one or pride.
Was it pride?
I feel like it was k one it was definitely an MMA fight.
It wasn't a kickboxing fight,
but it might've been pride,
but either way he see if you could find that.
Jeremy,
what did this,
oh my pride.
That's pride bro.
No,
it's k one dynamite.
Oh,
that's what it is.
Oh yeah,
watch this Brian.
Cause this is crazy because Melvin is,
I mean at the most,
at the most,
he's 200 pounds,
but I don't think it not to Honda.
I think he's one 95 yeah.
Well he fought Robbie Lawler 85 and strike force,
which means he's probably a little heavier than that and losing weight to get to
85 so let's say he's 95 what's this sound?
The benefit of the doubt.
So mark is at least 60 pounds heavier than him.
Maybe that Japanese shit folk.
And it happens in the first round.
He's got two seconds in.
No,
those are pride gloves.
It was the same as the k one gloves.
They were a,
they were just different.
They look like they were more padded than they were.
I count fast,
man.
Hope it's,
look at this.
Boom,
boom.
Oh my God.
Taught him coming in.
Wow.
Dude.
I would say it's worse because it's flatlined.
It was for a short guy.
Never fought in the UFC.
Melvin never caught.
Just fucking put some,
oh we went to the body.
Her Sjogren's.
Not fucking around everybody.
There we go.
That's it.
There's only so much you can take,
dude.
You see?
Oh Wow.
Shit kidding me.
We were watching an old fight while the new one was going on.
I got double knockdown at the velocities of fucking warrior.
The shoguns too much.
Holy Shit.
God.
Now,
if shogun decides to go out now after that respect,
respect goes out,
it goes back to rising.
Um,
revives his career with the TRT
top five after this
nice place for older MMA fighters to go to.
Well,
it would be nice if there was a place like pride was in its glory days and if
it's rising,
so be it.
There's that Russia clipped him,
he caught him coming and clipped him right in the jaw.
See,
I put the brakes on to the body,
to the body and cardio.
How does it build it?
And it's just part on like that boom,
that's smelling blood in the water.
Oh boom.
Oh,
this is ruthless.
That is a fucking phenomenal combination around tires.
But look how he doesn't,
he just clipped him with that right hand.
That true.
The body to the body there.
I like how he does it.
He doesn't rush in here.
How do you keep the distance so maximum power hip.
Oh Man.
Fuck No.
So good.
That's so incredible.
Great Wind for Shogun.
Fuck Craig whinge when I makes me feel good when he wins.
For some reason I'm crazy.
It must have been in Brazil to hear that roar.
It must have went crazy.
Fucking pulls it off.
Oh my God,
I'm so glad.
I don't know what happened either.
I don't have a clue
what is poor.
I mean,
I'm not sure.
Something good.
Yeah,
he's never been had the right body pull.
Hot means like Fuck Paul.
Hi Paul fucking man body.
He's a dime piece.
This is going a man's body.
Brazil real lady polar.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
He's a man and I'm,
well,
he's a,
he's also the sporting legend over there.
He's like Michael joining the streets of Chicago over the,
let me stop.
Probably not that much,
but dude,
him and [inaudible] and Samson.
Leo was saying,
one of the reasons why he lives here.
She goes back there.
They can't even go out to eat,
man.
Really?
But she didn't do anything really.
It's one of the reasons I live here.
It's just crazy.
Like he goes back all the time,
you know?
But for like v Tor Amston Liotta you're shopping and big,
big nog.
But think about bigger stars.
I mean,
it gets the Brazilian soccer team,
but those are,
that's the shit,
man.
Brazil fighting peanut butter and Jelly Sun.
That's a good point.
Here.
We're like,
Eh,
whatever.
I bet hoists,
voice calls over there.
It's probably preposterous.
Yeah.
Gracie.
Yeah,
probably can't we can Tim Tebow style you can't go anyway.
There's a lot of fun movies coming out,
man.
This life one looks kind of interesting.
Did that new alien.
See the way,
I can't wait for that.
That's terrifying.
Great.
Uh,
all those movies were amazing to have anything to do with the other ones.
Is it?
Oh yeah,
it's about before.
It's about before you know how they pitched that movie?
Legend has this wasn't Prometheans kind of medias from ets before the more
recent one.
Yeah.
I liked promethium.
Promethium has something to do with alien.
Yes.
That's the start.
The idea is that big guy in Prometheans,
those weird alien people looking things,
those were aliens from another planet.
They got jacked by the alien alien first
prometheus's when that gigantic star ships spaceship crashes on top of that
chick and kills.
No,
she crawls out from underneath.
Well some protected her.
It's the movie the whole super,
super important that they follow.
The child didn't fucking have anything to do with it.
You know what they say?
The,
the legend has it has soul that the alien in the movie,
like in the room when they walked in,
the producers went,
so what's your pitch?
And they went cias and space you interested in?
They're like,
yes we are here.
Well they that HR Giger guy,
that artists sort of revolutionized what we thought horror monster.
So He created something that was so entirely different than any other alien
landscape.
A foreign,
very dark and evil and say tannic in some sort of a weird way.
And also that alien itself was so much different than any other idea.
We had always had this idea of like the super intelligent things from other
planets.
If someone was like,
no.
How about a giant bug thing that just eats everything I could find and grows
like that.
Plants.
It's egg in your body.
Yeah.
How about guys watch salient you guys into that?
No.
Fuck that noise.
As soon as they started doing that all the time.
Sorry,
I said it.
What was that?
Dracula versus the wolf man.
I like,
I don't like when they mixed them Predator though.
They should.
They have like Predator versus fast and furious.
All those shit racing their cars on residential roads.
I'll get mark by Predator.
I'd pay for that.
I watched one of those fast and the furious the other day and we were like,
how many of them were there?
And then we looked it up.
There was 10 10 of them making a bunch of them fucking movies.
There was 10,
10 81 right now.
What really on the eighth one,
Ryan,
come on.
They're doing more though.
F Eight is coming.
Why did it say 10?
When I go to the,
well they might be under contract with 10.
They're doing more Joe,
is that what it is?
You,
uh,
you know the redoing Predator without our own,
first of all,
how can you just pull that out?
How do you know how many fast,
why would you,
why would you have that infamous?
Paul's a big giant like billboard or on their way here,
like at a Hollywood and whatever Franklin or something.
I don't get down with those action movies,
man.
Do nothing for me.
It says there are 10 fast and the furious movies in the works I'm contracting
to.
Who's going to play hardball with New Predator?
Enjoy that rush or the,
you know,
the remake and Scarface.
Who's gonna play fucking Tony Montana?
Vin diesel confirms fast and furious.
Eight,
nine and 10.
That's what it is.
Just pushed avatar back.
Hold another year.
Ah,
Fuck Jamie.
Why something yesterday,
James Cameron probably drown somebody accidentally.
Dude,
one of his crazy ass fucking submarines.
Dammit.
I mean,
how did you release?
Have to fucking how many years?
15 years later.
It's two lost to be sick though.
Entourage fucking movie talk.
Compare those to you,
son of a bitch.
Bitch Avatar to PR.
Oh my God,
that's an 18 when was it supposed to come out?
Jamie?
2018 when he's supposed to come out this year is supposed to come out next year,
but they pushed it back farther.
When's it going to arrive?
Maybe 2019 wow.
So it will be 10 years.
Wow.
Oh No.
Look what he says though,
son.
We're not making it up to a two.
We're making an Avatar.
Two,
three,
four,
and five.
They're making all them.
Epic undertaking director says a franchise around 2009 blockbuster.
So they're going to do them all together.
Forgive.
And so they're going to have one.
They're going to release another one and then another one afterwards.
I'm waiting
and I loved it.
Did you talk to assholes?
Yeah,
we loved it.
It was amazing.
I loved it.
Loved it.
Game changing.
Share with a cliche.
Well,
it's the hottest.
It's Pocahontas from Delhi.
Amazing Stat too.
It's,
it's,
well,
you know,
there's only so many fucking real archetypal stories of heroes.
Vito Belfort,
Kelvin gasoline.
Here's my take on this.
I think Calvin's gas is fucking hugely superior,
but if [inaudible] can swarm him in the first round,
he's been known to be able to put anybody on Queer Street one round to get it
done.
But I'm telling you,
Kelvin Gaslamp takes a punch about as good as any fucking human being alive.
His,
his jaws.
Amazing.
He never see Calvin get hurt.
I mean,
he's a tank,
he's an excellent wrestler and he knows how to win man.
He know how he went to win on the ultimate fighter when nobody sort of thought
that he was going to be winning that show.
Everybody's looking to Uriah Hall.
He tuned up.
Can't Tim Kennedy,
I mean he tuned him up,
man.
That was,
yeah,
he's saying file insane fight.
Tim is making it safe for democracy so,
well,
you know what it is?
Tim trained for two different fights and went through two camps and a,
I think he was really overtrained and he looked like he wasn't recovering well
in that fight.
That's what has a lot of other options,
you know,
and he's kind of half in,
half out maybe.
But I don't think that's what did it,
man.
I think we did.
A man is his cardio and he's known for his cardio.
So I think what happened,
he cut,
not even think it's the weight cut as much as it's overtraining and all us,
his training partners think that it's overtraining,
but it's also Calvin gas alum.
I mean Calvin might've got him even if he had everything going for him because
Tim is like a thick,
solid,
super strong grappler,
but kind of plotting on the feet,
you know,
he doesn't throw anything with lightning fast precision.
But Calvin,
the punches come like lightening man and they,
and he does,
he doesn't load up on his punches.
He's constantly moving and constantly moving in and out with his foot work.
But he's getting a lot,
but he's getting better fast.
When you see improvements fight after fight I was,
I was never really on the Kelvin train and then after that one I was like,
God damn you going to be trouble.
Especially at 85 I think the top five is going to be a real challenge for him.
But outside that he's a monster to do when they show the TRT v I was going to
send him on.
Trt is literally so night and day.
It's ridiculous.
It's insane.
So scary.
But he knocked out Dan Henderson and I fight the last one.
There was no TRT.
Chris had been kind of,
that was about,
well,
how about more saucy?
We saucy beat the fuck out of them.
Takes off.
[inaudible] went through the first round,
survived the storm,
said what he was gonna do.
He said,
I'm going to take him in the first round and I'm going to knock them out.
And as he took them out of the first round,
he took him into the second,
took them into the second and just wore his ass out.
Vito just can't sustain.
Look at Victor.
That's cal Calvin,
the no victor.
I'm sorry.
Sophie tournament master.
I'll tell you why I like Kelvin with his confidence and he had zero fear.
Yes.
One of the nicest guys on the planet and well spoken.
No fear of hurting and enjoys marijuana.
Is that true?
I'm not.
It's no need to discuss this further,
Huh?
Good.
Hey guys,
like natural
medicines.
That's important.
That's big time.
But in pink he does like natural medicine.
I'm a big fan.
Big Fan.
Look at victor dancing in the background.
Who is victor?
Victor Davila that he's one of the 10th planet.
Blackbelt Huh?
Okay.
Cause he trails Ebi and he does the um,
the,
my job for the UFC in Spanish.
Hey,
let him have this slide off.
Do they?
Well that's cool.
Beautiful.
So he could do this and then he trains out of kings to fulltime now Keller,
he doesn't have a song in his head over there.
He lives in,
he lives with master event.
They live together like best friends now.
Oh Shit.
Wow.
Where did the adult not specific to beach.
Okay.
That's a good spot for if you're going to be a fighter.
Yeah.
Something about Orange County man.
Especially down the beach area.
Like Huntington beach in particular.
Man,
there's a lot of great gems,
especially Jitsu.
There's just all sorts of things going on.
Well La in particular,
Matt,
I mean is there another place?
It's more of a hotbed for martial arts,
like on the level that this place is like New York and La are the two,
I'd Say New York and Florida.
Florida's giant.
The what?
What la doesn't have is it doesn't have like an American top team.
We have like a one wealthy guy who funds this gigantic organization on La North.
Northern Cali does though with a k and then team Alpha Man.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
But Dan Lambert,
what he's done down there in southern Florida,
something special.
It is mixing around for over to Dan Lambert conflict down there and dumped a
lot.
Oh cash into that a lot.
Oh cash smart guy.
Man Loves MMA.
Loves it.
And then he was like,
he's what?
You would really want a knowledgeable guy for sure.
Pull that crack up.
A little booty crack.
They're distracted by his legs.
Pull it up.
Ooh.
Powerful.
All cell phone stuff to you guys.
This is new stuff.
Every fight he's got something new.
Who's this television don't spinning kicks.
Throwing crazy shit on the ground.
On the ground.
He's,
he's 10 clinic guy too.
He got some brown belt.
Nice.
Well,
Calvin has a really impressed the shit out of me to his footwork.
His movement like is so light on his feet narrow.
He leaps in and pop side Jab.
Oh,
we turned the straight left.
He turns looking good and bad.
Kelvin and Tony First and I'll have that same kind of mentality.
Just that fricking know fear.
Mexican walls have fun.
Have Fun in the [inaudible] if they want to be in there.
Yeah.
Oh they love it.
They love what percentage of Mexican is Tony Ferguson?
Hundred percent he's 100% but the last name is Ferguson and his Stepdad.
Ah.
Oh Wow.
A little bit of white flavor on them.
I'm liking the way I Mike and the look and features eyes.
I'm liking the creasing in his neck.
I'm feeling like he's coming in with more than dad bod.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Well,
you had dad bought of the in,
how would that be possible?
Okay.
Didn't see the way and didn't see the way in,
but there was only 24 hours,
but sir didn't see it.
Just saying talking because a lot of things can change in 24 fucking hours.
That's what I'm trying to tell me about rehydration.
The body,
while he looks intense.
Yeah,
he does look fucking into,
this is my point for the less strong jaw.
Haven't seen his job.
That look that strong and a long time told him,
man,
why don't you marry him?
You guys don't know what happened.
No idea.
Have no idea.
I don't know Twitter.
I do not know I post it.
I'm not telling me.
I'm so proud of myself.
This is the first time I've ever watched a fight card without having any idea
what was going to happen in any of the fights because there was no more a box
boxing on.
He didn't look back yesterday.
By the way.
That's more than dad bod,
dude.
It definitely looks better than he looked against.
He does.
He looks absolutely.
It's better than he looks.
More aerodynamic.
Way more aerodynamic.
Yeah,
Dude,
look at him right there.
That definitely looks better.
Like this right here,
we're seeing a rehydrated.
He looks better than he looked at what he does when he went into the room
against Weidman into the octagon,
rather like you could see his loose skin jiggling around while I was jumping up
around.
Yeah,
that was rough.
Yeah.
Come on man.
Let's go.
He looks not bad there.
It looks aggressive.
You should take a powerful older man.
Hey,
well wait.
That's what he is.
Whereas when he was on TRT,
he looked like a science project because that's what he was.
He's a fucking side.
How old is he now?
38 he's 39 or 49 he's been fighting for 20 years past some of that sweet,
sweet wine this way.
Sorry Buddy.
I've been
natural medicines.
Oh,
I got some of that.
I've got a blanket Betty.
A little more.
Jamie.
Remind me to bring
a couple of guys hanging out.
That's true.
I'm not doing nothing.
I won't present cause
I got you.
Let's definitely not talk over each other and definitely not give any
smart man.
He's smart.
He's my,
here we go,
folks.
Here we go.
Vito Belfort fucked.
Yeah.
Joanie,
flip through.
No,
no,
nope.
I'm giving him an inch a wine.
Ah,
you such a Nazi.
You fucking,
he knows.
Eddie knows he doesn't want to go crazy.
Eat Pizza Gate.
All right.
He doesn't want to do it on
the path.
What I'm saying here we go,
main event folks.
It's just kids.
Who cares.
Just drive me to the comedy store.
You know that right am I don't have my car.
All right.
That'll put your feet up on my car.
And when the pound your Dick and
why don't you have your car,
Brian?
Uh,
well,
I didn't know we were doing the podcasts at for,
no,
I called him.
I just don't want you to be talking with today's whatever five really posted
this morning.
Whatever
pictures
you call him on my kid.
I don't think I've ever liked the picture.
Well,
that's not good.
That's why people are gonna like years now.
I
don't know.
Not don't mean it in a personal way.
It was just bad on social media.
I just don't read a lot of,
that's probably good too.
Yeah.
Damn.
Kelvinn looks so calm.
It was cool to Rafael Cordeiro Cole.
He's the best,
nicest guy.
Oh Man,
I love that guy.
I love it when it,
when guys that are involved in the sports,
such a violent sport can be like sweetheart dicks because they'd been humbled.
Like everybody who's really gotten in the sport has been knocked out.
It's been humbled.
You know what I mean?
Possible to be cocked.
Rufus,
super cool.
The nicest,
nicest guy.
Conor McGregor is cocky as he seems when he loses or wins.
He's always gracious.
Brian.
I met him for the first time last weekend and Cody Garbrandt,
Cody,
I'm sorry.
I don't know a Gary.
Super Nice Guy as well.
After he did that,
he had that kid with them and stuff.
That guy can do no wrong hoodie.
Garbin your next best thumbs marketing.
He's awesome.
Vr.
That kid,
he just showed us commercial,
but yeah,
he's the real deal.
He looks like a shit starter,
you know what I mean?
But he's not super nice.
The skills to back it up dressed as well speaks well.
World champion,
last beat,
Dominick Cruz.
I know.
It's interesting when you see him,
when that full suit and you see all the neck tattoos,
you're like,
Ooh,
this is interesting what he's doing here.
He's like polishing up a murderer.
He's when he's inside that octagon.
Did he use pit bulls?
Toenails
fans in Brazil?
Huh?
So hard looking man man.
Oh they go crazy for him.
Here we go.
I'll look at that.
Calvin looks so calm.
No one is more calm in there.
Nobody.
Calvin.
Part of the reason is cause he takes such a good shot.
I mean obviously he's really good and he's just confident period.
But Calvin's got that Chin is fucking iron that has to help you.
Right?
Cause you know you can make a little mistake and still get away.
Get Away with.
That's chuck in his prime.
And Chuck's prime,
one of his biggest assets was his chin.
Chin was phenomenal.
Man.
See now watch how good Calvin moves on his feet.
He's real light is in and out.
So count like much distance.
He covers forward and back.
Just to let you know he's nowhere near you.
He's Kinda close.
Changed.
He's nowhere near you.
Oh,
you could switch it up,
man.
It's a pain in the ass.
As Unorthodox as possible.
He's into that.
It's important because from the South Pole position,
he shuts down that high kick.
It's much harder for me.
So,
so Victoria has to kick off of that left,
or excuse me,
off the right.
That was a little snap kick to the,
to the chin.
Nice short,
sweet door.
It's going old school,
man.
I'm not mad at it.
Oh,
most wheel kick.
Don't get caught with [inaudible].
Everybody calmed down.
He's got some hands.
He's still got the speed.
Speed doesn't go in your 38 40 when you're veto our guys.
Is He?
Oh
Shit.
The just feeling very explosively shit.
Oh my God.
Towards fastest posts still.
And he's,
he's always moved.
Amazing.
I mean,
Peter's House about his prose.
Kelby,
he can't do this for every round five rounds.
Yes.
Five minutes.
A few.
Yeah.
This is a five round main event.
Oh,
he's talking Hazel.
tell me I clipped they're a little bit,
I love the way Kevin,
I'm raises his hand.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm telling you man,
Calvin,
we'll start.
Ooh,
good kick to the body there by V tour.
Oh,
yikes.
Kevin would be able to pour it on with vittores starts to wilt and that's what
it's going to get interesting with Kelvin to try and grapple to at all.
And the thinking about tore too is he's never really,
except for the rumble fight,
the role fight.
He actually did come back from behind.
Right.
And he was losing that fight.
Yeah.
Oh Geez.
Easy with those knees.
He was losing it.
Oh.
Oh,
he's hurt.
That's straight heartland.
It's hurt.
It was that right hand there.
That doesn't really hurt.
His head got snapped back.
Glade is no hands down.
He throws a little straight left.
This Kelvin compared to Tim Kenny.
Kevin different animal looks even better.
He's so good.
And he's so young and he's been lifting two to move into one 85
his hands are smooth man.
And he fires jabs like his body can be at off angles.
Yeah,
like his distance.
Especially.
He's not a long time.
No,
but he used it.
Oh,
she tried to kick again.
Oh wait to get out of there.
Oh Wow.
Oh,
oh,
that's over how boy.
Oh,
that's over.
Stop the fight.
So hold on.
Goddamn.
Who's is it Mario?
He's kicking up.
Is it Mario?
They could have easily.
They could easily stop.
Oh,
Kelvin,
you get earn this.
Earn this.
This is Brazil guys.
This is fucking Brazil.
Relax.
Everybody calmed down.
He loves her that.
Oh,
that's his shit.
Wrong side though.
It does.
It does it.
It matters.
It's going to be tough.
There's no room.
I'm in them out.
You don't even need to get on the side.
That's old school.
You can't move though.
Eddie with the cage.
Right?
Look at before getting back.
Oh my God.
If he talked to our backup.
Wow.
You got to give it up.
He survived.
Kidding me.
Oh,
it's big.
John's the rough big John McCarthy.
Wait,
it goes.
Come on guys.
John made it happen.
Kidding me right now.
Probably is wobbly.
Did throws giving it back.
Yeah,
he did and a great [inaudible].
He's still dangerous.
We towards still dangerous,
but he's not on unsteady legs.
That's straight left.
Comes down the pipe.
That's true.
That contact him.
He tagged with that Jab.
Jab is so crisp.
Who's that?
Kelvin's his pumps and nasty and he throws that Jab,
right hook.
Oh fucking hands,
man.
Oh Jeez.
Tell what Jews in a row.
He wouldn't be
one was barely up.
He covers a lot of ground with those labs.
He comes.
It's weird cause you didn't have a long reach,
but he keeps great distances.
Footwork,
you know what is has wide as shoulders.
I think if you measure his shoulders of,
okay,
I think he's pretty.
Now let's talk about this.
Because Calvin had been talking about going down to one 70 and you look at how
good he looked in Tim Kennedy fight and then looked even fucking better against
Vituro standard like him at 85 stop depleting himself.
Said one 85 he looks like a fucking world champion.
But Holy Shit,
look at that left good Lord.
Bang distance.
Oh my goodness Joe.
Here's his,
here's he.
He went to a what?
A split decision.
Woodley.
So what?
Boom.
Yeah,
but you know why he went to a split decision.
Well,
when does that happen?
Who knows?
What does that up?
Well,
two one,
two.
How the first one was barely off.
Then he adjusted,
adjusted like straight down the pike at John John McCarthy.
Good job.
All the way around to yeah.
Not Style but and John then stop and then when it was over fucking amazing hands
giving big John's the Paris fucking amazing.
How about Calvin?
What a,
what a fucking rent him better refined.
Jesus Christ.
What do you do next with them?
Years coach.
What would you do next with him?
Title Shot.
What can go Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
You're his coach.
Yep.
What came out of shot jumps,
jump.
John [inaudible] here's the question.
What about when question,
if you're making people away,
but hold on.
So if you're making this big GSP,
Michael Bisbing super fight,
do you make Yoel Romero versus this month?
No.
No,
no.
You don't do this.
Yeah.
No,
that's Joe and
Joe's got a mischievous mind right now for the extra title
trouble maker.
What do you say about that?
No,
it's too much for Kelvin.
We'd take the worst matchup possible for them,
right?
Yeah.
Not Get man.
Cause he,
you know,
that's an older veto.
Let's not get crazy.
He beat Tim.
Kenny had one foot out Ramirez the same age,
but y'alls you [inaudible] Victoria A.
Little different.
They're a little different.
A little bit,
little bit difficult.
That comes after one and he's good.
The other year we don't know.
I'm different.
I would like Kelvin to fight a guy like I think a great fight off.
So you'd have to beat Musashi.
I'd like to see why been verse Calvin.
I think that'd be a fun fight.
I don't want to top fourth three guys.
Not yet bill.
He's 25 if you use your y'all,
what do we do?
I really hope he stays at one 85 and I think he could be a champion.
I think he's got everything it takes to be a champion,
but bring them up.
Scalzi be who knows how the fuck did he beat this guy?
How the fuck,
how the fuck did Michael Bisping beat him?
Give him some time in Michael Bisping
beat Rockhold gimme gimme you might lose to terracotta or he might tune rock.
Hold up the same way.
Saw Him do to beat towards tonight.
You don't know.
And he's a great fighter.
I mean that kid,
his movement and his accuracy and his combinations,
his punches is fucking phenomenal.
His ability to survive on the ground against Tim Kennedy in that first round and
like virtually burned,
no energy came out of that,
survived and then started beating the shit out of Tim and you're like,
well,
maybe Tim Kennedy did really overtrain.
Maybe he's not really preppy.
Look what the fuck he did tonight.
There's a big difference between Vitor Belfort at 38 off TRT and the jock gray,
Yoel Romero and Luke Rockhold.
Big Difference.
You're right.
Any beaten?
Yes.
Right now we know difficult,
but this is the next step,
right?
How's that?
The next step?
The next thing?
I think the next logical step.
I feel like Calvin is top 10 top 10 yes.
Candy fight.
I think he was 10 what was he ranked up to?
The Kennedy file,
isn't he like he don't know.
I think he's nine and he and he might be 10 feet towards nine.
I don't pay attention.
So if that's the case,
I feel like he's in the top six or seven now.
I think he's moved up.
Right?
This is a phenomenal performance.
He's two and Oh,
at middleweight he looked amazing against and on the feet.
It was all in the feet against one of the best trackers in the game.
Who did you go?
Aw,
when you saw vittores phase 10 Devon's 10 I bumps mail.
When I see a number 10 right before this fight is Robert.
That'd be a fun follow.
Jesus Christ.
There's a fucking,
Barbara Whitaker has a barn burner coming up.
Chalker Ray.
Oh Damn.
That's going to be,
that's a fucking fight.
I don't think you give Calvin to Jocko rate or any of those guys.
Did you know a result of this fight,
Eddie?
Yeah.
You knew what rounded and the whole deal.
I didn't know what round it was at the first round.
Yeah.
What about Derek Brunson or Anderson Silva?
Mm hmm.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
But wait a minute,
why this is not current?
It can't be because v towards still it had,
well,
they're not going to update it tonight.
Right.
Um,
but the fight was yesterday.
I would've thought that Mike has said probably wait till Monday.
But yeah,
look,
that's a crazy division.
Right?
And Derek Brunson and Anderson Silva just getting done with their fight.
Robert Whittaker Brunton makes sense out of that.
It's not a big name fight though for him.
Yeah,
but you got to him still a Brunton.
Robert Whitaker has a date.
Messiah says date.
Why men's date Souza?
Everyone's,
everyone has a date for Rochel.
Yeah.
And Rockhold has been talking about Bisping.
He's waiting for,
Bisping wants to kicked,
put Bisbee and just be doing,
even have a date.
So what are you going to do?
Rockhold where are they going to do that fight?
They don't know.
Do they?
They have,
even now,
they may even,
is this the first time never announced a fight without a date or a venue or I
feel like it's gotta be the 4th of July weekend,
right?
You would think,
yeah.
If you want to knock something out of the park,
what does it say there?
Bisbing versus Saint Pierre.
Does it say a number?
You'd go look over there and that little picture it says March 3rd press
conference.
Oh,
okay.
So they don't have a date.
I would imagine if we're
looking wordy in March,
April,
May,
June,
July,
four months from now.
That's very reasonable.
Right?
There's something with GSP.
He didn't want to fight.
Well,
that's Sean Jones weekend too,
you know,
that's when Jon Jones returns.
Jon Jones,
I,
Anthony Johnson and John Jones.
Oh.
Oh Jesus.
That's going to be Jon Jones coming back and joy that one on the undercard of
Bisbing versus GSP.
Holy Shit.
What a card.
Oh boy.
What a card,
dude.
Hey,
what?
Eddie Bravo.
What happened with you and Michael Bisping on that?
We heard that there was this crazy argument and there's a video of you guys talk
about,
it seems like you're working it out.
He's my friend.
It's like,
you know,
when you're arguing with your friends,
there's like,
people are like,
oh,
what are they going to fight?
Not For one second.
Did I think a fight?
What's going to go down?
You know?
Um,
you know,
every time I,
I,
you know,
talk about Mike Bisbing or anyone else,
they usually say if he visibly improves from fight to fight,
you could see it.
And I,
you know,
I'm sure he's sick of hearing that and I was talking about that I was
complimenting him,
but then I could see how he thought like that implied that,
you know,
he was,
uh,
you know,
subpar at one point,
so it was like,
I take offense to that man.
I,
I was always a bad ass ever since the,
uh,
the ultimate fighter show and I,
and I,
I,
I understand where he's coming from,
you know,
so it was just a misinterpretation of what you were describing.
Yeah.
And then we just started talking about like,
you know,
he's fighting GSP.
He's a good dude,
great guy.
We were,
we were arguing and he was getting like,
kind of like insulted.
He was like,
I'm insulted when people say that.
I'm like,
I'm sorry.
I get it.
I was trying to compliment you.
I'm,
I'm saying,
I'm trying to say good things about you,
but I see how you could see,
I should,
I should have kept my mouth shut.
Was there a couple of adult beverages going around too?
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
By the end of that conversation,
if they didn't have a guys.
Yeah.
He's like,
dude,
I should come up and,
and trying to do,
cause I'm finding GSP,
you know,
he's going to want to take me down.
I should get good off my back.
I'd come up,
you know,
we were
very blessed that he didn't remember.
So that's what makes him great.
He's to give you the,
I know we're all cool.
He Dm me on Twitter,
says,
Dude,
sorry about last night.
I go do it.
Don't even trip.
And I should have kept my mouth shut.
Is was the biggest fight of his life coming up at the ghost.
These just fight for GSB.
That's a tough fucking fight.
It's a business.
Take down defense.
Who says it's easiest fight for GSP.
That's crazy.
He's way bigger.
Michael Bisping is a legit one.
85 of 42 oh five,
I remember he won the ultimate fighter.
Oh my God.
Look at that combination.
Kaz and Kelvin.
Just circle one to look at that again is shown it again.
Fucking incredible.
He looks so good.
God Damn.
I'd be one legend.
So it'd be another one.
Calls out.
Spider Anderson.
The old man.
I don't know why it's not.
It's a good idea.
Fighting these legends.
Smoking.
Um,
I don't know if I want to see that man.
You know what I'm saying?
I'd rather see that than him.
Verse Jocker a or some,
Derek Brunson seemed like,
like he was hypnotized by Anderson.
He got too much respect for him.
There was moments where in the face,
so he just didn't seem like,
it just didn't seem like he found his groove in that.
Plus he was him coming off of the knockout loss to Robert Whittaker.
He's on a long tentative little switched the time.
Yeah.
He tried to go a little technical again.
Bad idea.
No one wants,
you know,
the fans lost on that fight.
They'll fight sucked.
How dare you.
Oh,
sorry.
It wasn't the most fine.
It wasn't the best flag.
Yeah.
Totten Grisham.
Um,
I honestly have not listened to him at all.
because the last time he was doing something we were doing a fight companion.
So we talked over this work.
Who's
Karen Bryant for this?
I think Canada and then uh,
he didn't really take Goldberg spot.
Well he's,
he's doing some of the ones that Anik would have done.
An antique has kind of taken up Goldberg spot.
I like you and dom together,
the chemistry.
You and Tom is the best for me.
I think I like him.
I liked doing it with him and I liked doing it with DC too.
I liked both of them.
Makes Bisbing so incredible is not only did he eve,
is that the fact that he's,
he got the belt basically with a half an eye to that's got,
that's got to play.
He did after years,
man.
Like he's been grinding.
He deserves the morning.
He never got a call for any PA.
Dot.
All claims to only PD guys really?
Like he's been fucked man.
Then he becomes champ on a seven day notice shooting a man ass knocked out Luke
Rockhold no Silva but and then he revenge is his loss against Dan Henderson.
It's not his story.
So cool man.
It is a crazy story.
It's beautiful.
I mean it's,
it's all just heart and we'll look at this common nation man,
him and Vito.
I mean,
oh see how he tagged him with that jab snapped his head back.
We're still got that spinning kick though.
It keeps you looking for it though.
Oh Jesus.
He gets his head snapped back.
Big John.
That's a function of a smell.
A younger,
faster guy.
Well [inaudible] Stevie toward never had combinations like that.
Fee towards combinations were like straight line blitzkrieg attacks would,
Calvin's doing is hitting these crazy angles with beautiful precision.
Like if you look at the way he's delivering his punches,
it's really some next level shit.
He's one of the best punchers in MMA right now because what he's doing is he's
sliding in and he's not loading up on these shots.
He's throwing them with perfect efficiency and just Tatainia [inaudible] in his
[inaudible] straight straight everything.
And he moves his body side to side really well.
Like he look how he's like,
look at like,
Oh man,
it's beautiful.
The Way Lens at lefthand,
it's fucking phenomenal.
Hardest Shit to look at this.
Come on straight down with that left hand.
Good Lord.
Look at this.
Don't Dank without an elbow.
No,
no.
Just punches,
man.
Excellent.
Oh,
what a beautiful shot.
Overwhelmed.
Ever bring that shit into my fucking cage.
[inaudible] 1980s show that got canceled after two episodes.
You know?
No.
Did a group of mercenaries in the cage fight on the side to path to choose
whether they work for the government or pursue a career in cage fighting.
Cage fighting wasn't even a real thing.
I make a fucking choice.
They had cage fighting,
but that's why those pka karate shoes from like the 1980s and they wore long
will those long shiny pants.
Remember those karate paths and he had the black belt on it over the shiny
pants.
The one that Brian's do we say awesome things like this in mind.
When we want to leave,
we got like this.
I go,
hey guys,
let's blow this fucking joint.
I say that and then,
and then I felt like the whole joint and then I go like this.
I go and when we really want to get my voice,
when I go,
let's fucking go.
So g o with a lot of bows after moving out that the funk,
you don't like my fucking homie because it's man shit.
Let's go get some fucking burgers after we left.
Or we hear when other people are talking about what happened.
What?
Dude,
I'm fucking not even letting me fucking,
Eddie was talking.
It wasn't martial arts movie called no rules as frank shamrock scinet Randy
couture's.
Then it Tom Sizemore,
isn't it?
When he's like Todd sign needed cash and he's like,
it's rehabs and everything.
He's in the movie as the main fight or Thomas Iso hell and he wore a sweater
when he fought like a loose sweater.
He was like in the worst shape of my life.
No rules you God.
I'm going to see.
Why don't we,
here it is.
Look up at the screen left that we should do.
Why don't we do this?
What I was going to say.
It's amazing.
Pamela Anderson's brother wrote the script.
That sounds like a bad idea.
Ah,
hold on.
This trailer to look at a fire behind Mullah Anderson.
Pamela Anderson was in it in two.
I'm five.
I'm only supposed to be in it,
but I,
I failed because I had a seminar.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm proud of you Eddie.
Jacques was going to be an a,
he bailed for Tom Sizemore for sure.
He was proud of you and we're not doing this.
Why did they agree to have Tom Sizemore and the sweater?
Was that like the stipulation is that they could get him?
Oh
yeah,
I remember Dave,
you always have to have the see where he's contemplating what he looks super
important to [inaudible] 87
and uh,
there's an evil fight team and they do,
when they do Omoplata as it's like a satanic thing,
they kill you with Elma,
Blah.
No joke.
Frank Shamrock is part of the evil fight team at the tap out.
They killed people.
Oh,
is that his handle?
Shit.
She made a cameo.
She did this and Barb,
why threw something at him?
Oh,
face.
Whoa.
That guy's done with the backfill,
the upper cut that launches the dude upside down and back sheet
real John.
Jack was going to be shooting back.
So they called me up,
backed out,
and I,
and he goes,
do we need another villain?
And I knew Randy couture was thinking about being in movies.
I said,
maybe I could call Randy.
So I called Randy.
I know you want to do a movie.
Uh,
they need a villain.
Last minute,
Randy couture jumped in and he did it.
So now if we,
if we do something like this,
it almost can't be a standalone thing.
We really almost need some of the dialogue.
We
need to hear what the fuck we're referring to.
It's a great movie.
Now is this a movie that they can get online?
The evil fight like a French Hammer.
Greg,
Gary Busey,
the Satanic Fight Club.
Frank Shamrock,
shamrock
satanic fight team.
Look at Gary Busey the best dude.
I can't believe no one's career boomed up.
I broke his back.
Shoulders.
That's MMA bible.
Let's Randy Young.
Randy coture.
This is like amazing.
What is Randy up to these days?
Anybody talked to him?
He was so large.
Look at that Randy and he was on our show a little bit ago doing the damn thing.
Yeah.
What's he been doing?
He's doing,
he's involved with that fighters' union thing and then he's making movies.
Which fighters' union thing isn't there like three of them?
They're all Duke martial arts associate Athletic Association and then there's
the union.
He's part of the union.
What's the better one?
Oh,
there were training montage.
Super important.
So show your destiny hunching ropes and stuff.
Yeah,
McKinney water.
This is an amazing moving this just like my life in the 80s man,
when I ran with that game,
this is my nineties called the,
Oh this is just taken after it was taken off of my dragon gang that I used to
run with.
No rules was seriously.
That was right when the ultimate fighter was made that movie.
So they're trying to capitalize on that shit.
No,
they probably didn't know about it yet.
It was probably like in the process they saw how it really goes down like,
ah shit.
Damn it.
There's no Satan worship in heaven.
I remember reading the script part of what
they must have.
I bet if we had a show where we just want to run back to where they should,
they should be happy.
I bet if we had a show where we just watch bad movies and did a companion for
bad motors,
there's,
you'll never run out of movies.
You never read a shitty movies.
You know what they told him that he'd go work,
sit in play now you give everyone a week's notice on Monday,
go,
hey,
we're watching a fucking naked gun on Friday playing it now and everyone has
naked
done chews it up.
Yes.
And then we all watched it together.
Yeah,
like Greece.
I was watching Gracie in the night with John Travolta and I,
I mean I made a um,
uh,
send a text message to Jamie.
I said,
we should do a fight companion for the movie grease to cause that was high and I
was watching them then multiply and I'm losing control
your supply.
It's electrify
the producer that just said,
dude,
if you can't be fucking Randy couture,
make your parts so much bigger.
And I'm like,
whatever.
Then I bailed like two weeks later.
I got to find a way to pay a bad idea.
It was that Satanic Alma plot does that got me.
It got John,
John,
John.
Jack said he let somebody read the script.
Oh port.
This will ruin your name.
You can die from an Omoplata.
Does your arm just rip off and you bleed or what?
You know what?
I never got,
I never got them right.
You do.
You get there like 20 minutes and you're like,
cool.
I get it.
20 minutes
series of movies like that,
you get a bunch of them.
This is my favorite commercial,
Patrick Swayze and roadhouse.
I'm getting a tiny pony.
Yeah,
but Patrick Swayze and Rose House is almost been done to death.
I live tweeted at once.
I'll watch the or instagrammed it.
I know,
I realized how homoerotic it is.
It's insanely homoerotic.
I went through a whole series of tweets where like I highlighted what their
quotes were,
what the fuck they said.
Do you want to say the gay scene of all time is the volleyball season first top
gun.
Go ahead.
Pull that up to the whole thing that,
this is an interesting story.
This is a whole thing that Quintin Tarantino put in a movie,
but apparently it's something that uh,
Roger Avery thing,
there's like,
you could read it up online,
but it's apparently Roger Avery theory that,
you know,
Roger Avery would make killing Zoe who's a brilliant actor or brilliant
director,
writer and a wound up killing a guy in a drunk driving accident wound up doing
jail time and it was like tweeting from jail.
Damn.
If I remember correctly in the early days of Twitter,
I'm not making that up.
Right.
Is that isn't that the case was tweeting I think from the early days of jail.
But this top gun according to Tarantino,
according to Roger Avery was his theory is like say if you had a theory and you
were always talking about it,
you'd polished it up and made it really funny and he told the shop and shop goes
on like Fox News and starts talking about here's my theory B and like he just
rattles off your stuff.
That's kind of what he did allegedly.
What was he saying about it?
Well it's just that top gun is gay,
like couldn't tear.
And Tito goes through this whole thing about all the different various moments
where you realize what the hidden subtext is and it's all homosexual isn't
really,
I don't know that she's hilarious.
Can can't play it.
Oh they'll kick us off of youtube with the,
but we'll play it after the podcast.
Volleyball seen that.
No,
we can't play the Quentin Tarantino dissection of top gun because if we do
they'll kick us off of youtube cause it's not our context that the actual movie
right there it is.
Everything gets kicked off youtube.
People own their content.
You know,
if you,
if you make something,
whether it's a movie or a song or anything and someone puts it on a youtube
thing and then puts it up on youtube,
this shut it.
They shut it down.
Shut down for showing a planet earth to the Lizard.
Grown from snakes.
They shut it down like minutes.
Oh yeah.
Well all those,
apparently that's one of the most lucrative video segments is the animal tax
segment because people love watching those animals attack other animals and tag
people.
And anytime does a video like that,
if you throw that shit up on Facebook,
it's going to get your page shut down.
Yeah,
it's happening.
Quickness too quick and they shut my page and I for like three days,
there are a little bit cooler but it's gonna eventually bleed over to that too.
Cause doesn't Google own Instagram.
Facebook owns Instagram.
So serious is the same thing.
There's going to hit here's Kinda poster.
Goddamn fucking reptile.
Yeah.
But the problem is somebody owns that reptile video on youtube and they're
making money off the ads and it's real money because a lot of those videos,
it's hundred percent fair,
fair look,
we just want to see it.
Okay.
If I can put it up on my page and show everybody,
and that's cool too,
but I just want to see it.
So if people are showing up,
whatever's going to make sure these people put up more of those videos as good.
I mean,
I'm not in the fucking animal tag video business.
You know,
it'd be cool.
It'd be cool is if you repost a video from planet video,
whatever planet attacks,
animal tax,
and then they get paid no matter what because you're always follows.
They still get the pay.
But you can get a show that maybe they want to generate more subscribers under
their page though,
and the argument can be made who had it somewhere else.
It's somehow or another Mike keep people from subscribing to their page.
That's the argument.
We did this thing on fighting the kid three day where I had,
I put on a deer suit and print and put on a lion suit and I had to kind of run
away from him,
like on my hands and knees,
like on my hands and feet.
It was for the sketch and he would come over and just jump in the air and land
on me.
I was so fucking worried.
My back was going to break every single time,
but I was just thinking about how ridiculous that fucking sketch was.
We were both dressed as a little bit rejects.
Then when we're talking about real animal attacks,
well,
it was very similar.
Yeah,
but it just gives you a nice opportunity to talk about fighter and the kid three
d,
which is available now.
I don't even know if it has.
Fox owns that,
but they're not releasing Barack up.
Yeah.
Since we separated a no divorce made all those sketches and now people can't
watch them.
It's a bright man,
but they have to pay.
Do you know what?
It's all over online.
Everybody's dumb.
Don't pay from them to do some research.
You can find the leave.
What your sister and some of them are good.
I'm pros finishes and UFC pride.
Wec Strikeforce history shogun right up there with 17 Donald Serone 17 Vandelay
20 and cro cop number one,
cro Coppin on Mount Rushmore.
Oh,
that's a good question.
Five,
he never not in the UFC.
He never really performed to the best of his ability in the UFC.
He also never looked this well.
Who knows what that's all about.
You know,
but he never looked the same when he came from Strikeforce or excuse me,
pride over to the UFC.
The UFC did work.
Kim K one champion rise.
It's fucking nuts.
Well,
you know he got back on the Mexican supplements,
let's be honest.
But he was also a Mexican summons for a little bit during the UFC.
Let's be 100% exemption.
You think he had,
he was on TRT exemption.
Really?
He had TRT?
I think so.
Well don't they have to announce that though?
No.
Hell No.
They don't have to know how many people had it.
Oh Man.
A good amount.
And then because the floodgates open because once people found out other guys
were doing it,
they had to put a stop to it because you have to get,
go through certain people to get it and then you know,
it was just a bad look because once you know how if the advantage and everyone
wants to do it,
yeah,
it was weird for a few years because it was legal for a few years and everybody
was like,
what are they doing with Terry do TRT fucked,
you know the flood gates open.
But then they're like,
no,
hell no.
Hold on.
Wait that like the,
she'll levels like you could be doing that stuff every day.
I mean what,
what,
what are they,
as long as you're staying under some ridiculously high level and some of them
that did get caught,
like one of the reasons why it got shut down,
it was when they caught Veit tour and he was at like 1,470 and the doctor was
like,
well this isn't even healthy.
Like this is like a dangerous level.
Same thing with Nate Marquardt.
When Nate Marquardt got popped,
supposed to fight Rick story and then he want to fold it fighting Charlie
Brennan.
That was last minute replacement.
It was like they did his levels then went what the fuck's on?
Like they ain't no way you're fighting like this.
This is not healthy.
Like you're on some silver back gorilla levels here.
Yikes.
What isn't there,
aren't there different like there's free testosterone.
How does that work?
Well you'd have to talk to a real total is free endocrinologist but with you
know they would explain what's available to you,
what your body has to process,
what you're,
what your levels are and then they can also find like it all depends on when
you've eaten a,
how much sleep you've gotten.
Yeah.
If you worked out what kind of a meal you've eaten,
depending on like that's why these blood tests are kind of ridiculous.
Like I talked to a doctor,
literally told me if you wanted your growth hormone levels to show up as low,
all you would have to do is eat a really heavy meal.
Like right before you got your blood tested.
I get like how far before he was like 45 minutes an hour should do it and it was
just eat a bunch of cheeseburgers and shitty food and fries and milkshakes and
then just go in there and he goes,
you'll have such a crash.
Insulin levels,
your growth hormone levels,
everything's going to be all fucked and out of whack because you just threw some
sludge in your system.
So how's the best way to check your true resting testosterone over a week?
Yeah,
you should chest it.
You should get a mean.
You should try it,
test it and should be.
You should write down what you're eating,
how much you're sleeping,
and then you know,
and then also the,
one of the things that has big effect on testosterone is how much cholesterol
and how much saturated fat.
And people for the longest time of course,
thought it was the opposite.
They thought that that stuff is bad for you,
but now they realize that's actually the precursors for testosterone and other
hormones and fat,
saturated fat.
Your body needs cholesterol and saturated fat to convert to testosterone.
So when one of the things that people find in John Rollo found this out,
he was one of the first people to tell me about this.
When he switched up to a Keto diet,
his testosterone went way up.
He was way up.
Yeah.
It happens with a lot of,
yeah.
Yeah.
Your insulin levels are very,
you know,
your,
your whole state like during the day changes because you don't have the,
the crash thing.
Like last night I ate in the late afternoon and then I didn't eat this morning
so I probably went till I have,
so I had some butter coffee this morning at like 10:00 AM and I had maybe eating
at like three in the afternoon along fast,
fast.
But it doesn't bother me at all because of my body's just used to burning fat.
Yup.
Oh I had some exogenous ketones to,
I had some of that like an hour later.
So your,
your body,
my body is on full ketogenic state so I'm just burning the fat all the time.
And when,
when you do that,
you don't have the,
that weird crazy like I've got to eat now thing cause if I but allows just
burning carbohydrates and I took that much time off of eating,
I'd be frantic,
like really frantic and he won't be able to think and stuff even when my energy
levels are perfect.
I did two sets last night at the store.
Perfect.
No problems.
Like,
yeah,
when you live off fat it's wave as opposed to glucose.
You,
you definitely,
your,
your appetite is way more suppressed.
Way more suppressed.
Yeah.
Just for that benefit alone.
I like it just that because it keeps me from thinking about it so much because
when I'm,
when I go,
like I fucked up,
um,
maybe a week or so ago,
not even last weekend.
Yeah.
But we can go,
I took uh,
like one Sunday and I went off.
That's a good time.
I had pizza,
I had a Cuban sandwich,
I ate all this bread and shitty food.
And then I took me like a few days for my body to get back into a state of
ketosis.
But once I did that man,
I was so hungry like soon as my body started flipping over to the calorie to the
carbohydrate side because you need any more glucose because your body,
you go through glucose very quickly,
you only have a few hours of it.
So you have a meal hungry again.
Yeah.
Your body is a few hours of it and then you got to refuel again.
It's really interesting too to have to go soon.
So I have a set [inaudible] store you on tonight too.
Yup.
Well whose show is that?
Uh,
I,
it's for,
it's for an animal rescue thing and by the way,
the end of this month,
March 30 31 April one I'm at the American comedy camp.
That has nothing to do with what we're talking about.
Some she might date.
He's just throwing in some plugs.
Yeah,
I'll be,
I'll be in San Diego.
It's a great club.
I know.
That's a fun place to ever do.
La Jolla.
Do you do the comedy store down there?
Not Anymore.
And I miss her.
Joe.
Oh,
April 27th.
I'm glad you brought that up.
So it's amazing finding kid.
April 8th and ninth,
DC.
Philly.
Oh yeah.
For one plug to,
I'm going to be at evolve a slash 10 planets sync Singapore for a week,
super camp,
two classes a day,
Monday through Friday.
And then there's a one fc show on that Saturday.
It's May 21st,
all that week,
two classes a day.
Uh,
contact evolve.
MMA is going to be,
they're bringing you in to do the,
um,
the seminar and then you're going to stay for the fights and watch the fights.
I'm doing two classes a day.
It's like a crazy kid camp seminar week.
So you're doing that and then you're gonna stay for the fights.
Yup.
One I've seen somebody should fucking snatch you up.
Would you be willing to do that thing that you used to do for the UFC?
We used to do the scoring in between rounds.
I'd rather just lots of fights,
man.
I'm going to,
I'd rather just watch it,
watch it right here.
Right.
I'll do it.
Like,
what do I know?
Come on.
This is the most fun place in the house to watch the fights.
They should give us a booth ringside and let us fight companion.
Just just give us the biggest radio all the time.
You out to see who would be paying attention.
Like if you have those commentary options,
like you have it on fight pass,
you could listen to it in espanol,
you can listen to it.
You know this should be,
you go through the corners.
There should be an option for fight,
fight companion.
If we had a fight can pay option.
We showed up and we showed up and we had like a fucking smoke,
poof booth sound proof booth Jamie,
Jamie up there with like DJ lights and like a DJ table and a smoke proof room
and just feels good.
That'd be crazy.
Do you know going to be,
the reality is no,
we're not trying to brag here,
but the reality is way more people listen to this then then watch these fights
and that's true.
The last one.
I mean,
we've gotten,
you know,
with youtube and with a iTunes,
we've got as many as 7 million people downloading and watching these things.
Yeah.
Fuck.
How much is that?
I start doing my hair,
but it's like there's no way this got 7 million people.
This may maybe got a million.
No coffee.
No,
no.
This might have got a Fox sports.
Maybe millions.
Good million's not bad.
But here's the thing.
Well,
we're not taking into consideration is how many people watched in Brazil.
It might be way over a million because it's veto,
right?
Oh Shit.
That straight left.
Maybe it might be way over a million in Brazil.
I mean,
we're not getting the global numbers,
right.
We're getting the fs one numbers as we hire people to translate this in
Portuguese.
No talking.
Imagine Bravo bright and me and you.
You're the problem is the humor would translate.
Someone would fuck up our jokes.
He goes,
these guys suck.
I know this doesn't matter.
As long as somebody with a sexy voice to Dub Maine,
uh,
know a little about today,
he just talking into the microphone in your face.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Dare you.
I'm going to leave on that note.
Let's wrap this bitch up
and we're going to try to do next a Saturday night or Saturday afternoon,
two in the afternoon.
Right there.
I'm bringing birthday.
Oh,
happy birthday cake.
That's it.
We've got a lot of,
a lot of podcasts this week.
See Ya.
Bye.